Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. When does fast grocery delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without the grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner.
感谢收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。什么时候通过 Instacart 购买生鲜快送最重要？当你的招牌粒状芥末土豆沙拉没有了粒状芥末就变得不再那么出名时。当烧烤架已经点燃，却没有什么可以烤的时候。当亲戚们突然决定实际上他们要留下来吃晚饭时。
Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer, so download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus, enjoy zero dollar delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees exclusions and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Wendy's most important deal of the day has a fresh lineup. Pick any two breakfast items for
这个夏天，Instacart 为你包办了所有的生鲜杂货，赶快下载应用程序，享受最快 60 分钟送达服务。此外，前三笔订单还可享受零元配送费。服务费、排除条款和适用条件均适用。Instacart，让生鲜配送超越期待。温蒂汉堡（Wendy's）当天最重要的优惠活动推出了全新阵容。任意挑选两款早餐只需
five dollars. New four-piece french toast sticks, bacon or sausage wrap, English muffin sandwiches, value iced coffee, and more. Limited time only at participating Wendy's Taxes Extra. Why do fintechs like Float choose Visa? As a more trusted, more secure payments network, Visa provides scale, expertise and innovative payment solutions. Learn more at Visa.ca slash fintech. It was after dreadedultova's day, when fortune left the royal Swede. Around a slaughtered army lay no more to combat and to bleed. The power and glory of the war, faithless as their vain votaries' men, had passed to
五美元。全新的四片法式吐司条、培根或香肠卷、英式松饼三明治、超值冰咖啡等等。限时优惠，仅限参与活动的温蒂汉堡门店，税费另计。为什么像 Float 这样的金融科技公司会选择 Visa？作为更受信任、更安全支付网络，Visa 提供了规模、专业知识和创新的支付解决方案。了解更多请访问 Visa.ca/fintech。那是可怕的波尔塔瓦之战后，命运抛弃了皇家瑞典人。屠杀过后的军队横卧在地，再也无力战斗与流血。战争的力量与荣耀，正如其虚荣的崇拜者们一样不可靠，已经转移到了
the triumphant Tsar, and Moscow's walls were safe again. Until a day more dark and drear, and a more memorable year, should give to slaughter and to shame, a mightier host and haughtier name, a greater wreck, a deeper fall, a shock to one, a thunderbolt to all. The beginning there of Lord Byron's poem, Mzeppa, which he wrote in 1819 and obviously Dominic he was writing there in the shadow of Napoleon's invasion of Russia and the failure of his attempt to capture Moscow. But Byron, although he was famously obsessed by Napoleon, is still very much aware that the Great Northern War, this great Titanic clash between Charles XII of Sweden and Peter
凯旋的沙皇手中，莫斯科的城墙再次安全。直到一个更黑暗、更阴沉的日子，以及一个更值得铭记的年份，将给屠杀和耻辱带来一支更强大的军队和一个更傲慢的名字，一场更大的残骸，一次更深的坠落，对一个人是震撼，对所有人是惊雷。这开头的诗句出自拜伦勋爵的诗作《马泽帕》（Mazeppa），他于 1819 年写下这首诗。显然，多米尼克，他当时是在拿破仑入侵俄国以及试图攻占莫斯科失败的阴影下写作的。但拜伦，尽管他对拿破仑有着著名的痴迷，却依然清醒地意识到，大北方战争，这场瑞典的查理十二世与俄罗斯的彼得
the Great of Russia, that that conflict was more than fit to stand comparison with the storm and drang of the Napoleonic Wars. And it's kind of tribute, isn't it, to just how deeply the events of the summer of 1709, a century on, continue to reverberate through Europe. Yeah, absolutely, Tom. And it's interesting, isn't it, that in the English speaking world, I think by and large the Great Northern War has now been forgotten or slightly overlooked. I think it's been eclipsed, hasn't it, by the War of Spanish Succession and then the Napoleonic Wars and then of course the World Wars of the 20th century. But at the time when Byron was writing, these characters, Peter the Great, Charles the 12th and the
大帝之间泰坦般的巨大冲突，这场冲突完全能够经受住与拿破仑战争的风暴与压力（Sturm und Drang）的对比。这某种程度上也是一种致敬，不是吗？致敬 1709 年夏天的那些事件，在整整一个世纪后，依然在欧洲激起如此深远的回音。是的，绝对如此，汤姆。有趣的是，在英语世界里，我认为大北方战争现在大体上已经被遗忘了，或者说被轻微忽视了。我想它已经被西班牙王位继承战争，然后是拿破仑战争，当然还有 20 世纪的世界大战给黯然失色了，不是吗？但在拜伦写作的时代，这些人物——彼得大帝、查理十二世，以及
character who gives his name to that poem, so that's Ivan Mazepa, The Hetman. The Hetman of the Cossacks, who we talked about last time. These are great romantic heroes, aren't they? They are individuals standing astride the course of history and shaping it to their will. I mean, that's how people like Byron thought about it. Yeah. And they are heroes with a deep shade of darkness. Well, we've already had the tremendous business of Charles the 12th Foot, which we were entertaining our assistant producers with just now because they
那首诗中同名的人物，也就是伊万·马泽帕，盖特曼。哥萨克的盖特曼，我们上期节目聊过的人。这些都是伟大的浪漫主义英雄，对不对？他们是傲然挺立于历史进程中、并按自己的意志塑造历史的个我的确，拜伦他们就是这么想的。是的。而且他们都是带有深重黑暗阴暗面的英雄。好吧，我们之前已经见识了查理十二世那只可怕的脚的壮举，刚才我们还在跟助理制作人们津津乐道呢，因为他们
missed yesterday's recording. I know. So a boot full of blood and splintered bone, squashing. There's loads of blood and splintered bones to come in today's episode and indeed the final episode of this series. And behind all this is a really major political and diplomatic shift. It's because what we're talking about today is one of the most decisive battles in European history.
错过了昨天的录音。我懂的。所以一只靴子里装满鲜血和碎骨，黏糊糊的。今天的节目中还会有大量鲜血和碎骨，事实上，本系列的最后一集也是如此。而这一切的背后，是一场真正重大的政治和外交巨变。因为我们今天谈论的是欧洲历史上最具决定性的战役之一。
It's the death knell of one empire, the Swedish empire, the birth of another, the Russian, and it redraws the map of Eastern and Northern Europe for centuries to come. Well, right the way into the present. I mean, the consequences of the Battle of Pultova are with us right now. They are indeed, absolutely. So Tom, shall we remind ourselves where we've got to
这是一场帝国的丧钟——瑞典帝国的丧钟，另一个帝国——俄罗斯帝国的诞生，它重新绘制了未来几个世纪东欧和北欧的地图。嗯，一直延续到今天。我的意思是，波尔塔瓦战役的后果直到现在依然伴随着我们。确实如此，完全如此。那么，汤姆，我们要不要提醒一下大家我们讲到哪里了？
for those people who are not members of the Restless History Club and are not continuing directly from episode four? Go for it. So the Great Northern War has been raging since 1700. People remember that the Swedish Empire are facing this coalition of Denmark, the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth and Russia. Charles XII had invaded Russia in the summer of 1707, planning to reach Moscow and dictate terms to end the war there. But everything went wrong. People remember that his supply
对于那些不是“一切皆历史”俱乐部会员、没有直接从第四集接着听的人来说？说吧。大北方战争自 1700 年以来一直在激烈进行。大家记得，瑞典帝国正面对着丹麦、波兰立陶宛联邦和俄罗斯的联盟。查理十二世在 1707 年夏天入侵了俄罗斯，计划抵达莫斯科并在那里通过 dictation 结束战争。但一切都出了差错。大家还记得，他在勒温豪普特伯爵（Count Löwenhaupt）率领下的补给纵队被击溃了。瑞典人有很多糟糕的表现。他们喝醉了，不是吗？军纪涣散，我想这样说挺公正的。所以查理决定改变计划，进行一次大规模的转移。
column under Count Luevenhaupt was routed. There was a lot of poor behaviour from the Swedes. They got drunk, didn't they? In discipline, I think it's fair to say. And so Charles decided to change his plan and to go on a massive diversion. South, away from Sweden. Yeah, away from Sweden and away from Moscow into Ukraine where he would team up with the Cossack leader, Ivan Mazepa. They had that terrible winter, 3,000 men froze to death,
向南，远离瑞典。是的，远离瑞典，远离莫斯科，进入乌克兰，在那里他将与哥萨克领袖伊万·马泽帕会合。他们经历了那个可怕的冬天，3000 名士兵被冻死，
and now Charles has been cornered outside the town of Poltava, some 200 miles east of Kiev, and he is outnumbered at least two to one. He has had this terrible foot injury and nearly died, but then he's come back from the dead, and on Sunday, the 27th of June, he summoned his generals and said, come on, let's do this. Let's just go for it. Death or glory, a final showdown to decide
而现在查理被逼到了基辅以东约 200 英里的波尔塔瓦镇外，他的兵力处于至少二对一的劣势。他受了可怕的足部伤势，险些丧命，但随后他又死里逃生；在 6 月 27 日星期天，他召集了将军们并说道：“来吧，我们干吧。放手一搏吧。不成功便成仁，来一场决定这场战争命运的终极对决。”多米尼克，他向来都是这样的人。因为只要遇到疑问，他就会进攻。
this war once and for all. And Dom, that was always what he was going to do. Because if in doubt, he attacks. Exactly. He's very much... Of the Custer and Alexander the Great and Nelson school of thought. He absolutely is. And these are tremendous friends of the rest of history. It's fair to say that Custer does sometimes let himself down, doesn't he? So darkness falls on the Sunday evening and let us sketch the scene. The Swedes are camped west of this fortress of Poltava. There's about 30,000 Swedes.
完全正确。他非常属于...卡斯特、亚历山大大帝和纳尔逊这一学派的思想。他绝对是的。这些人都是“一切皆历史”的忠实朋友。不过说实话，卡斯特有时确实会让人失望，对吧？所以在星期天的傍晚，夜幕降临，让我们勾勒一下当时的场景。瑞典人扎营在波尔塔瓦这座要塞的西侧。大约有 30,000 名瑞典兵。
And that's about half the force that Charles had set off with. Yeah, and he's been hoping for all these reinforcements from the Crimean Tatars and the Poles and whatnot, who remember didn't turn up at the end of the last episode. But his assumption is that one Swede is worth 10 Russians. And that's pretty much everybody's assumption because the Swedes are the finest fighters in Europe. The downside of course is they're frozen, they're sodden, they've got no feet, they've got no gunpowder and no food.
这大约是查理出发时兵力的一半。是的，他一直期待着来自克里米亚鞑靼人、波兰人等等的增援，大家还记得，他们在上一集的结尾并没有出现。但他的假设是一个瑞典顶十个俄国人。这几乎是所有人的假设，因为瑞典人是欧洲最优秀的战士。当然，负面影响是他们快冻僵了，浑身湿透，没有鞋穿，没有火药，也没有食物。
But even so, they still kind of fancied their chances because they're so good. Now behind the fortress on the other side is the river Vorskla, which runs north to south. So you've got to imagine that on the right-hand side of the picture. Further north, on the same side of the river, the western side, as the Swedes, are 80,000 Russians under the Peter the Great, his top general Boris Sheremetyev and his great drinking pal Alexander Menshikov, who we talked about before. Now if the Swedes do want to attack them, they're going to be charging north towards the Russians and they will have to get past six defensive earthworks, which are known as redoubts. I do love it when you talk military dispositions.
即便如此，他们依然觉得自己有胜算，因为他们太优秀了。现在要塞的后方，另一侧是沃斯克拉河（Vorskla River），这条河由北向南流淌。所以你必须想象它在画面的右侧。在更北边，在河流的同一侧（西侧），也就是瑞典人这一侧，有 80,000 名俄国士兵，由彼得大帝、他的顶级将军鲍里斯·谢列梅捷夫（Boris Sheremetyev）以及他的大酒友亚历山大·缅什科夫（Alexander Menshikov）率领，我们之前谈到过他。现在，如果瑞典人想要进攻他们，他们就必须向北冲锋迎战俄国人，并且必须突破六处被称为“棱堡”（redoubts）的防御性土方工事。我就是喜欢听你谈论军事部署。
Oh, love it. Well, that's nice. So there's more redoubts to come. Each of these redoubts are about a hundred feet tall and the Russians have built them on the road from Pultava. So they're kind of like makeshift forts, I suppose. If the Swedes can get past these redoubts, they will reach Peter's camp. And Peter's camp has been fortified with this big earth and ramparts and trenches and loads and loads of cannons. So it's effectively a fort.
哦，太喜欢了。那真好。所以还有更多的棱堡要登场。这些棱堡每一个大约有一百英尺高，俄国人把它们建造在通往波尔塔瓦的道路上。所以它们有点像临时堡垒，我想。如果瑞典人能够突破这些棱堡，他们就能抵达彼得的营地。而彼得的营地已经用巨大的土方胸墙、战壕以及数不清的大农炮进行了加固。所以它实际上成了一座堡垒。
So the Swedes, they have all to do. And Peter, I think is very confident that he will win this for the first time in this entire story, the Russians, you know, have the upper hand because really. If even a draw is a win for him because he has massive manpower, massive resources. He's on home turf. All he has to do is to avoid defeat. And he has issued that proclamation that you read very resoundingly at the very beginning of this series. Remember the address to the troops, you're doing this for your kin, for Russia.
因此，瑞典人面临着极其艰巨的任务。而彼得，我认为他非常自信自己能赢得这场胜利。在这整个故事中，俄国人第一次占据了上风，因为说实话。哪怕打平对他来说也是胜利，因为他拥有庞大的人力资源和庞大的物资。他是在主场作战。他只需避免失败即可。而且他发布了那篇你在本系列开头字正腔圆朗读过的公告。还记得对部队的演讲吗，你们这是为了亲人，为了俄罗斯而战。
Yeah, the one that Putin's so fond of. The one that Vladimir Putin is so fond of. Exactly. Now what's Charles thinking? Charles, he knows that his men are exhausted. They haven't eaten for about six months, all of this. However, he is still confident that their superpower, which is their discipline, their training, their extraordinary fighting spirit will be enough. And partly because of that, he says to Ivan Mazepa, look, you stay out of this. We don't need the Cossacks because they'll just get in the way and they're undisciplined and they'll be riding around shouting and stuff and firing randomly into
对，普京非常喜欢的那个。普京总统非常喜欢的那个。没错。那查理在想什么呢？查理知道他的士兵们已经精疲力竭。他们已经大约六个月没吃饱饭了，诸如此类。然而，他依然坚信他们的超能力，也就是他们的纪律、他们的训练、他们非凡的战斗精神将会足够。部分正因如此，他对伊万·马泽帕说：“听着，你别插手。我们不需要哥萨克，因为他们只会碍事，而且他们纪律涣散，只会骑着马到处大喊大叫，盲目地朝空中乱开枪。
the air. We don't want that. We don't need your men, which is an extraordinary thing to say. Yeah, considering he's only, I mean, there's 6,000 men and he's only got 30,000 and he's facing what, 80,000 or something? Exactly, 80,000. So Charles himself is not going to fight, obviously, because he's only got one workable foot and he's just on a stretcher. He's going to be with the infantry, but he's going to be carried the whole time and he's surrounded by 24 bodyguards. So he's not even really able, he can't even really sit up so he can't actually see the battlefield.
我们不需要那样。我们不需要你的人。”这是个极其惊人的说法。是的，考虑到他只剩下，我的意思是，对方有 6,000 人，而他只有 30,000 人，他面对的是大约 80,000 人还是什么的？没错，80,000 人。所以查理本人显然不会亲自作战，因为他只有一只脚能用，而且他只能躺在担架上。他将和步兵待在一起，但他会一直被人抬着，周围有 24 名贴身保镖护卫。所以他甚至无法真正坐起来，因此他根本看不见战场。
So he's just looking up at the sky. He's just looking up at the sky and everything is being described to him. And I guess that this is a real problem because he is an incredibly competent general. And as we have seen from previous episodes, his two deputies aren't. Well, do you know what? I think you're being too harsh there, Tom, because actually his deputies, I mean, we can talk about them. So the field commander is going to go to Field Marshal Karl Gustav Reinskild, who we talked
所以他只能看着天空。他只能看着天空，一切情况都得靠别人向他描述。我想这是一个真正的问题，因为他是一个极其能干的将军。正如我们从之前的节目中所看到的，他的两个副手可不是。你知道吗，汤姆，我觉得你对他们太严厉了，因为实际上他的副手——我们可以聊聊他们。所以战场指挥权将交给陆军元帅卡尔·古斯塔夫·赖恩舍尔德（Karl Gustav Reinskild），我们上次谈到过他，如果你还记得的话，他浑身都是弹片。他在一次意外中受伤，体内嵌满了弹片。他实际上被公认为欧洲最好的骑兵指挥官之一。他非常勇敢。他有一种瑞典式的坚忍。他的缺点是精疲力竭，身体不太好，因为体内全是弹片，而且正如你所料，他的脾气非常暴躁。嗯，换作谁都会这样，不是吗？每次你坐下，都能感觉到一块弹片刺进你的屁股里。而另一个人则是勒温豪普特伯爵（Count Löwenhaupt），那个把运送补给纵队搞得一团糟的人。现在，他也被视为一位非常非常能干的指挥官，他是瑞典最优秀的步兵将军。问题在于，赖恩舍尔德和勒温豪普特互相深恶痛绝。他们甚至懒得跟对方说话。通常这倒没问题，因为查理在掌控全局；但现在查理正躺着盯着天空。我的意思是，我确信他们很有能力，但他们不是天才。在这种情况下，你需要的是亚历山大·大帝那种级别的个人魅力和军事天才。我觉得这话说得公道。我完全无法反驳。查理十二世到目前为止展现的正是这一点。
about last time, who has, if you remember, he's full of shrapnel. He was wounded randomly and he's full of shrapnel. He is actually reputed to be one of the best cavalry commanders in Europe. He's very brave. He has that sort of Swedish stoicism. The downside with him is that he's exhausted and not very well because he's full of shrapnel and he's very bad tempered, as you might expect. Well, you would be, wouldn't you? Every time you sit down, you feel a bit of shrapnel and he's very bad-tempered as you might expect. Well you would be wouldn't you? Every time you sit down you feel a bit of shrapnel digging into your bum. Now the other guy is Count Löwenhaupt, the man who made a terrible mess of bringing in the supply train. Now he also is regarded as a very very competent commander, he's Sweden's best
（注：原文中19块包含了前面重复和部分重叠的内容，此处按整体语义翻译）
infantry general. The problem is that Reinskjöld and Löwenhaupt absolutely despise one another. They won't even really speak to each other. And normally it's fine because Charles is in control, but Charles is lying down staring at the sky. I mean, I'm sure they're competent, but they're not geniuses. And what you need in a situation like this is a kind of Alexander the Great level of charisma and military genius. I think that's fair. I can't disagree with that at all. Which Charles XII so far had provided.
（注：原文重复部分已在上文或上下文中涵盖，为保持一一对应，本段继续顺译后续情节）
Exactly. So as dusk falls, they make ready to strike the next morning. And their plan is this, just before dawn, they will move out very quickly. They will leave their artillery behind because it will slow them down and because their gunpowder is waterlogged. They'll just rush past these redoubts, ignoring the fire from the defenders. And then they'll form up on the plain beyond. The Swedish cavalry will clear out Alexander Menshikov's dragoons, and then the Swedish infantry will pin Peter's troops back inside this sort of encampment, and either they will
完全正确。所以随着夜幕降临，他们准备第二天清早发起进攻。他们的计划是这样的：黎明前夕，他们将迅速行动。他们会把火炮留在后面，因为火炮会拖慢他们的速度，而且他们的火药也已经受潮了。他们将直接冲过这些棱堡，无视防守方的火力。然后他们在前方开阔的平原上列阵。瑞典骑兵将清剿亚历山大·缅什科夫的龙骑兵，接着瑞典步兵将彼得的军队死死压制在这处营地内，要么诱使彼得的军队出来被消灭——我觉得这要求有点太高了，要么就把他们封锁在这座堡垒里直到他们饿死。瑞典人觉得，这真是个绝妙的计划，这肯定能成功。所以在晚上 11 点左右夜幕降临，大家记住现在是夏天，所以天黑得很晚。瑞典人拔营起寨，移动到集结地点。查理穿上了全套军服，佩戴着长剑，尽管他正躺在担架上。他被抬到前线，赖恩舍尔德、勒温豪普特等人正在那里等待。双方交换了口令，瑞典语的口令是“上帝保佑”（with God's help），因为正如我们上次所说，那是极其重要的一个要素。这些瑞典路德宗信徒认为自己在替天行道，上帝正对他们微笑着。在等待所有人到齐的过程中，赖恩舍尔德和勒温豪普特还没开始就大吵了一架。
lure Peter's troops out to be destroyed, which is quite a big ask, I think it's fair to say, or they will blockade them in this fort until they starve. And the Swedes think, well, this is a great plan, this is obviously going to work. So at about 11 o'clock night falls, we're in summer remember, so it gets dark very late. The Swedes break camp, they move to their assembly points. Charles has got dressed in his full uniform with a sword, even though he's lying down on the stretcher. He's carried to the front where Reinskild and Luevenhaupt and Co are waiting. The watchword is exchanged, it's with God's help in Swedish, because as we said last time, that that's a really important element of this. These Swedish Lutherans think they're doing God's work and that God is smiling on them. While they're waiting for everyone to arrive, Reinskeld and Lervenhaupt have this gigantic row before they've even started.
赖恩舍尔德冲着勒温豪普特大喊，他的话被军官们听到了，他喊道：“你们到底在哪里？”他说：“难道你看不到一切都一团糟吗？我不需要你的帮助。我对你抱有更高期望，但我发现我错了。”这显然不是...不，我的意思是，这不利于士气，对吧？如果在我们登上皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的舞台之前，西奥对我们说这样的话，汤姆，那绝对不是理想的准备。我的意思是，他确实这么说过。他对我们说话就是这个调调，但是...
Reinskeld shouts at Lervenhaupt and he's overheard by officers saying, where the hell are you? He says, can't you see that everything is in confusion? I don't need your help. I expected better of you, but I can see that I was wrong. Which obviously isn't. No, I mean, that's not good for morale, is it? If Theo said that to us before we went on stage at the Royal Albert Hall, Tom, that would not be ideal preparation. I mean, he does say it. He does talk like that to us, but...
我会崩溃的。我会畏缩。我会啜泣。但瑞典人可不啜泣。正当瑞典人不畏缩的时候，他们在黑暗中听到了一种敲击声，赖恩舍尔德派遣侦察兵去调查，他们回来了。他们有了一个惊人的发现。在夜色中，俄国人建造了更多的土方工事，
I'd have a breakdown. I'd cower. I'd whimper. The Swedes don't whimper. So while the Swedes are not whimpering, they hear this hammering sound out in the darkness and Reid's guild sends scouts to investigate and they come back. They've made a shocking discovery. In the night, the Russians have been building yet more earthworks,
这些棱堡正好挡在了瑞典人计划前进的道路上。瑞典人将不得不绕过它们。这意味着他们必须分裂成两个侧翼，从这些工事的两侧通过。正当侦察兵们消化这个消息时，他们在黑暗中被俄国人发现了，他们听到了夜色中的手枪枪声，听到了远方夜空中沉闷的战鼓
these redoubts right in the path of where the Swedes plan to advance. And the Swedes will have to go around them. And that means they would have to break into kind of two wings passing on either side of them. And just as the scouts are kind of digesting this, they are spotted by the Russians in the darkness and they hear there are pistol shots in the night. They hear the ominous sound of a drum
敲击声。于是他们跑回瑞典防线，把这件事告诉了赖恩舍尔德。赖恩舍尔德说：“看，我们显然要失去偷袭的奇袭效果了。我们必须在天亮前马上发起冲锋，否则我们将再也没有这个机会了。”查理十二世说：“干吧，太棒了。”太棒了。于是他们修改了计划。基本上，他们将把军队分成三个师。左翼是陆军元帅
beating far away in the night. So they get back to the Swedish lines and they tell this to Reinskegården. He says, look, we're clearly gonna lose the element of surprise here. We have to ride now before it gets light or we'll never have this chance again. And Charles XII says, you know, go for it. Brilliant. So they amend their plan. Basically, they're going to divide into three divisions, the army. On the left-hand side is Field Marshal
赖恩舍尔德，率领骑兵和三分之一的步兵。他们将从左侧绕过这些棱堡，急速冲过去，然后在对面的草地上列阵。然后是右翼，想象一下另一侧，是勒温豪普特率领的六个步兵营。他们将从这些棱堡的另一侧（最靠近彼得营地的那侧）通过，然后与赖恩舍尔德会合。这就留下了一个由一个叫鲁斯（Roos）的中将率领的六个步兵营组成的中路。他们对鲁斯说：“好啦，你负责对付中间这些堡垒、这些土方工事，在我们从两侧通过时分散他们的注意力。”
Reinskeld with the cavalry and a third of the infantry. They're going to go past the redoubts on the left-hand side, rush past them and then form up on the grasslands beyond. Then on the right-hand side, so imagine the other side, is Leuvenhout with six infantry battalions. So they'll go on the other side of these redoubts, closest to Peters camp, and then they'll rendezvous with Rainsgold. And that leaves a sort of middle division of six infantry battalions under a guy called Major General Roos. And they say to him, right, you deal with these forts, these kind of earthworks in the middle, distract them while we're passing on either side.
解释这一切所花的时间，可能比我刚才解释的时间还要长，而且他们解释得可能更加详细和连贯。他们已经耽误了大量时间。现在大约是凌晨 4 点，太阳开始升起，他们能听到俄国棱堡传来的第一阵大农炮轰鸣声。瑞典人终于开始前进了，那场景确实令人惊叹。就像雷德利·斯科特电影里的场景一样。太阳正在乌克兰的草原上升起。那一排排整齐的
Now to explain all this, they've probably took longer to explain it than I did, and explained it in perhaps a more detailed and coherent way. They've lost a lot of time. So it's now about 4 o'clock in the morning and the sun is beginning to rise and they can hear the first sounds of cannons firing from the Russian redoubts. The Swedes finally begin to advance and it really is an amazing scene. It's like a scene from a Ridley Scott movie or something. The sun is rising over the grasslands of Ukraine. There's these orderly from a Ridley Scott movie or something. The sun is rising over the grasslands of Ukraine. There's these orderly blocks of Swedish musketeers. They're marching over the steppes in their blue uniforms. There's the cavalry in their kind of blue
瑞典火枪手方阵。他们穿着蓝色的制服走过草原。骑兵们穿着蓝黄相间的制服在前面小跑和慢跑。很快他们就抵达了第一处土方工事。正如计划的那样，瑞典军队分裂开来，像海水绕过礁石一样绕过它们，而在中间，鲁斯少将的营队与棱堡陷入了苦战，实际上立刻就被缠住了。于是俄国人进行极其顽强的反击，鲁斯麾下的营队最终被拖入了一场漫长的交火中。所以他们被落在了后面，在这场争夺堡垒的战斗中就地挖掘固守，这意味着另外两个翼只能继续向前推进，从一开始就把瑞典三分之一的步兵以及哥萨克人留在了后面。
and yellow coats cantering and trotting on ahead. Soon they get to the first earthworks. And just as planned, the Swedish army kind of divides and they sort of go around them like the sea kind of parting around them, while in the middle Major General Ruse's battalions get stuck in against the Redoubts and actually get a bit bogged down straight away. So the Russians fight back very fiercely and Ruse's battalions end up getting dragged into a long kind of firefight. So they get left behind, they sort of dig in in this fight against the Fords, which means that the other two wings are pressed on and left a third of the Swedish infantry behind from the very beginning, together with the Cossacks.
没错，跟哥萨克人一起，被远远抛在后面。现在大约是 5 点钟，太阳完全升空了。按照计划，大部分瑞典军队（不是鲁斯手下这支部队，而是主力）现在正开进俄国棱堡后方的草原上。起初，赖恩舍尔德和他的部下们欣喜若狂。他们觉得一切都在按计划进行。查理被用担架抬了上来。有人正在重新包扎他脚上的伤口，因为伤口一直在流血。一些军官甚至说道：“陛下，祝贺您，一切都在按计划进行，
Right, with the Cossacks, so miles away. So now it's about five o'clock and the sun is fully up. As planned, most of the Swedish troops, not this group under Rus, but most of the Swedish troops are now moving on to the grasslands behind the Russian redoubts. And at first, Reinskjöld and his men are absolutely delighted. They think everything is going to plan. Charles is brought up on a stretcher. People are redressing the wound on his foot because it's still bleeding all the time. And some of the officers actually say, Your Majesty, congratulations, everything is going according to plan,
这将是伟大的一天。”然后赖恩舍尔德环顾四周，说道：“等等，勒温豪普特率领的军队右翼在哪里？他们现在早该跟我们汇合了。”而实际发生的情况是，勒温豪普特向右偏离了一英里多，部分是为了避开小堡垒里俄国人的火力，
this is going to be a great day. And then Reinscroll looks around and he says, well, where's the right wing of the army under? Lüvenhaupt, they should have joined us by now. And actually what has happened is that Lüvenhaupt has swung off more than a mile to the right, partly to keep away from the Russian fire from the little forts,
但也是因为他急不可耐地想要杀进彼得的营地，他甚至不在乎自己已经脱离了主力部队。他对军官们说：“说实话，我受够了赖恩舍尔德元帅像对待跟班或仆人一样对我说话。”你看，我的意思是你说他是个优秀的指挥官，但他看起来糟糕透了，总是到处乱跑还迷路。事实是，我们可能错过了很多，因为我们跳过了大北方战争的大部分内容。当时有很多瑞典对波兰人和萨克森人等的伟大胜利。好吧，他在这里可没给自己挣光。汤姆，你曾在战斗中指挥过瑞典步兵师吗？没有，但我认为，如果我有过，并且我拥有欧洲最好步兵指挥官的美誉，我希望我能表现得更好一点。我觉得你可不会像勒温豪普特那样表现得如此勇敢，因为赖恩舍尔德很快派信使去找他，说：“你在干什么？回来，回来和我们重新列队。”信使到达时，正赶上下令部下突击彼得营地南侧胸墙的勒温豪普特。为了让你对当时的实力对比有个概念，
but also because he cannot wait to get stuck into Peter's camp and he doesn't even care that he has become detached from the main body of the army. He says to his officers, I'm actually sick of Field Marshal Rainskjöld talking to me like I'm a lackey or a servant or something. You see, I mean you say that he's a good commander, he seems terrible, he's always wandering off and getting lost. The truth is we've probably missed out because remember we skipped over a lot of the Great Northern War. There were an awful lot of Swedish victories against the Poles and the Saxons or whatever. Okay, well he's not covering himself with glory here. Have you ever commanded the
那是 2,500 人在向 30,000 名俄国人发起冲锋。好吧，我的意思是，这很勇敢，但勇敢并不等同于军事指挥能力。不，不，这倒没错。但这体现了瑞典人惊人的自我信念，这在战斗中往往至关重要，是一个巨大的决定性因素。我的意思是，检验标准是看结果究竟好不好。我们拭目以待吧。完全正确。无论如何，勒温豪普特收到了消息，中止进攻。而且他永远不会知道......（原文重复）无论如何，勒温豪普特收到了消息，中止进攻。所以他说：“好吧，好吧。”他脱离了接触。他命令部下重新加入位于西面两英里处的主力部队。现在是
Swedish infantry division in battle Tom? No, I haven't, but I think that if I had and I had a reputation as being the best infantry commander in Europe, I'd hope that I'd do a bit better. I don't think you'd behave quite as courageously as Levenhout does, because Reinschorz sends him a messenger very quickly and says, what are you doing? Come back, come and reform with us. And the messenger arrives just as Levenhout is ordering his men to storm the southern ramparts of Peter's camp. And to give you a sense of the odds here,
6 点钟。大约在这个时候，彼得的火炮从俄国营地开火，猛烈轰击瑞典军队。瑞典人当然无法还击。为了追求速度以及考虑到火药受潮的问题，他们把火炮留在了后方。他们简直成了活靶子，有一次一颗炮弹甚至从查理的担架上弹开，但没有炸死他，所以上帝现在真的是在向他微笑。瑞典人花了好长时间才重整旗鼓。大约一个小时后，赖恩舍尔德派信使回棱堡去找鲁斯，说：“快点，抓紧时间。你们在干什么？别管那些堡垒了。”实际上，发生的事情是鲁斯完全陷入了困境，他的一半人马都在俄国人的火力下折损了。等他终于决定撤退时，他已经完全失去了方向，不知道自己在哪儿，也不知道发生了什么。到处都是浓烟，你根本看不清自己身在何处。他命令部下撤退到附近的一片树林里。这简直太像小大角战役（Battle of the Little Bighorn）了吧？完全是一样的场景。
that's 2,500 men charging 30,000 Russians. Okay, I mean, that's courageous, but courage doesn't necessarily equate to military competence. No, no, that's true. But it's an extraordinary sign of the Swede self-belief, which often really matters and is such a huge factor in battle. I mean, the test is whether it's going to work out well. So let's see. Exactly. Anyway, Lervin Hap gets the message, break off the attack. And he will never know matters and is such a huge factor in battle. I mean, the test is whether it's going to work out well. So let's see. Exactly. Anyway, Löwenhapp gets the message, break off the attack. And he will never know because he does break off that particular attack. So he says, fine, all right. He disengages. He orders his men to rejoin the main force. That's two miles to the west. So it's now
就在那时，缅什科夫的龙骑兵挥舞着军刀雷霆般杀到，这是一场彻头彻尾的大屠杀。鲁斯手下大约 2,000 人被砍倒或俘虏。这意味着瑞典步兵大约三分之一从那一刻起就被彻底歼灭了。俄国人付出的代价微乎其微。俄国人付出的代价微乎其微。俄国人此时没有损失多少人，而且当然俄国人也损失得起，因为他们人多。所以留在草原上的赖恩舍尔德等啊等，那个第三师却永远没有出现。到了 9 点钟左右，他说：“我必须做个决定了。”
six o'clock. At six o'clock around about now, Peter's guns open up from the Russian camp hammering the Swedish army. The Swedes of course can't fire back. They've left their artillery behind because of speed and because of water logging issues. They're kind of sitting ducks and at one point a cannonball actually bounces off Charles's stretcher but it doesn't kill him so God is really smiling on him now. The Swedes take a long time to sort themselves out. About an hour Rainscald sends messengers back to Rus at the Redoubt saying, come on, hurry
现在我们可以按计划进攻俄国营地，但他跟你一样，汤姆，他稍微谨慎了一些。他说俄国人的火炮正在造成惨烈的伤亡，人数比应有的少了数千人。实际上，你知道吗？我觉得敌我悬殊太大了。我们还是撤退一点吧。去跟那些留在行李辎重等物资身边的部队汇合。然后再看形势如何发展。我们不能在一场鲁莽的孤注一掷中拿一切去冒险。他下达了撤退的命令。他说：“好吧，准备整队撤退，向后行军。”正是在那个时候，一直坐在营地里的彼得大帝出手了，他孤注一掷了。这是彼得一生中最重大的军事决策，而且时机把握得天衣无缝。我总觉得这一定很像《王者归来》里的那一幕：米那斯魔古尔（Minas Morgul）的大门轰然大开，安格玛巫王现身，莫多的大军开出来进攻米那斯提力斯。事情就是这样发生的。基本上，突然间彼得营地的入口轰然大开，防御战壕上的桥梁轰然落下，然后成千上万的俄国军队从营地里倾巢而出，列阵准备战斗。他们手里拿着剑、火枪以及非常现代的刺刀，蓄势待发。所以他们以前是一盘散沙，现在还是吗？完全不是。过去每个人都说：“哦，俄国人毫无用处。”现在他们穿上了漂亮的绿色制服。他们训练有素。他们组织严密。这是瑞典人从未见过的那种俄国军队。而彼得就在那里。
up. What are you doing? Leave those alone. Actually, what has happened is that Rus has got completely sort of bogged down and he's lost half of his men to Russian fire. By the time he does decide to withdraw, he's completely lost track of where he is and what's going on. There's smoke everywhere, so you cannot really see where you are. He tells his men to withdraw into a nearby wood. So that's very Battle of the Little Bighorn, isn't it? Exactly the same kind of scenario.
他太显眼了。他骑着一匹奥斯曼苏丹送给他的阿拉伯马。他穿着绿色的近卫军制服。戴着黑色的三角帽。穿着大靴子。他个子好高。是的。他看起来令人难以置信地威风凛凛。
At that point, Menshikov's dragoons come thundering in with their sabres drawn and it's an absolute bloodbath. About 2,000 of Rus' men are cut down or captured. So that means really about a third of the Swedish infantry have been annihilated from that point onwards. A very little cost to the Russians. A very little cost to the Russians. The Russians have not lost many men at this point and of course the Russians can afford to lose loads because they have loads. So Reinskjold up on the grasslands is waiting and waiting and that third division never turns up. And at about nine o'clock, he says, I'm going to have to make a decision.
陆军元帅赖恩舍尔德对瑞典人说：“停止撤退，我们现在别无选择。我们必须转身，调头，准备战斗。”现在是 10 点钟。这是至关重要的一个小时。瑞典人的兵力处于难以想象的劣势。此时此刻面对面的兵力对比大约是：瑞典方有 5,000 名步兵，没有任何火炮；而俄国方则有 24,000 名步兵，配备了 70 门大炮。瑞典人深知他们面临着极其严峻的硬仗，他们能取胜的唯一途径，A 是上帝站在他们这一边，B 靠的是他们的精神、训练、勇气以及所有这一切。
Now we could attack the Russian camp as planned, but he's like you, Tom, he's a little bit more cautious. He says the Russian guns are causing absolute carnage, thousands of men short of what it should have. Actually, do you know what? I think the odds are too great. Let's fall back a bit. Let's rejoin the troops that we've left with the baggage and whatnot. And then we'll see where things stand. Let's not risk everything in a sort of reckless throw the
或者如果弗罗多把魔戒扔进末日火山，那是唯一的办法。完全如此。有一个精彩的场面，你懂的，雷德利·斯科特那种大导演会非常喜欢这个。赖恩舍尔德骑马来到勒温豪普特伯爵面前——就是那个他曾与之进行长期激烈宿怨的人。他向勒温豪普特伸出手说：“勒温豪普特伯爵，你必须去进攻敌人。”
dice. And he gives the order to retreat. He says, all right, prepare to march out and march backwards. And it's at that point that Peter the Great, who has just been sitting there in his camp, that he strikes and that he rolls the dice. It is the single most important military decision of Peter's life and the timing is absolutely perfect. I always think it must be like the scene in the return of the king when the doors of Minas Morgul crash open and the witch king appears and the great army of Mordor marches out for the attack on Minas Tirith. This is what happens. So basically, suddenly the entrances of Peter's camp crash open, the bridges crash down over
在陛下的服役中表现出你的荣誉。”勒温豪普特握住他的手说：“那么，奉上帝之名，愿他的恩典与我们同在。”所以他们言归于好。这是一个惊人的场面。非常感人。他发出了信号，瑞典人的战鼓开始敲响，他们开始前进，这条微弱的蓝色细线对抗着巨大的绿色新月形敌阵。
the defensive trenches, and then tens of thousands of Russian troops are pouring out of the camp and lining up for battle. They've got their swords, they've got their muskets and their very modern bayonets at the ready. And so previously they'd been a mass of shambles, but are they now? Absolutely. Everybody had always said, oh, the Russians are useless. Now they've got these nice green uniforms. They're very well drilled. They're very well organized. This is the kind of Russian army, the like of which the Swedes have not seen before. And Peter is there.
俄国人的火炮开火越来越快。它们在瑞典人的阵线上撕开一道道缺口，但瑞典人依然不断前进。他们不开枪，只是向前推进，（原文重复）向前，不断向前。俄国火枪手开始射击，所以是一场密集的铅弹风暴，但瑞典人还是继续前进。他们没有开一枪。他们想要近战，这真的很像特拉法尔加海战中的纳尔逊。
He's so conspicuous. He's on an Arabian horse that was given him by the Ottoman Sultan. He's wearing a green guards uniform. He's got his black tricorn hat. He's got his big boots. He's so tall. Yeah. He looks unbelievably impressive.
他们越来越近，坚定地注视着前方。终于，瑞典人冲到了他们面前。和往常一样，当瑞典人发起进攻时，那是一场火枪、刺刀和挥舞的长剑交织的风暴。他们不愧为欧洲最优秀的士兵。他们冲进俄国阵线，他们不愧为欧洲最优秀的士兵。他们冲入俄国阵线，开始将对方逼退。在右翼，他们把
And Field Marshal Reinskild says to the Swedes, stop the retreat, we have no choice now. We have to turn, wheel about, and prepare for battle. So it's now 10 o'clock. This is the crucial hour. The Swedes are unbelievably outnumbered. So the numbers that are facing each other at this moment is about 5,000 infantry of the Swedes with no artillery at all against 24,000 Russian infantry with 70 cannons. And the Swedes, you know, they know that they're really up against it. And the only way they can win is A, if God is on their side and B, they're just their spirit and their training and their courage and all of that.
绿制服们杀得步步后退。有一会儿，感觉瑞典人真的能成功。事实上，在这一切混乱中，传说彼得三次险些丧命：有一次瑞典人的火枪弹打飞了他的帽子，另一次瑞典火枪弹击中了马鞍，第三次瑞典火枪弹——我能猜到你要对此说什么了，汤姆——被挂在他脖子上的一枚曾属于君士坦丁大帝的十字架挡开了。这绝对发生过。是的，这当然发生过。这绝对不是来自俄国宣传的故事。当然，如果彼得倒下了，这场战役的结果可能会完全不同。
Or if Frodo drops the ring into the crack of doom, it's the only way. Exactly. And there's a wonderful scene which you would, you know, a sort of Ridley Scott star director would love this. Rainscroll rides up to Count Lovenhout, the man who, you know, with whom he's had this massive long running feud. And he holds out his hand to him and he says, Count Lovenhout, you must go and attack the enemy.
今天的欧洲地图可能也会不一样，但他没有倒下。上帝站在他这一边，而不是瑞典人一边。接下来发生的事情是我们在这档播客中做过的其他战役中非常熟悉的情节。随着瑞典人向前推进，他们左翼和右翼之间的空隙变得越来越大。彼得投入了更多的预备队。瑞典人被吞没并被包围，尤其是在右翼。他们的势头慢了下来，随着他们放慢速度以及俄国人蜂拥而至，他们的士气开始动摇，然后崩溃。接着第一批瑞典人开始逃跑，这种恐慌迅速蔓延。
Bear yourself with honor in his majesty's service. And Lovunhaupt takes his hand and he says, in God's name then, and may his grace be with us. So they've made up. It's an amazing scene. Very touching. And he gives the signal and the Swedish drums start beating and they begin to advance this kind of thin blue line against this vast green crescent.
就像他们的冲劲把他们带到了极限，再也无法前进了。有点像肾上腺素突然消退的感觉。完全正确。当你阅读战役记录时，很大程度上都关乎信念，他们的信念支撑他们达到了非凡的高度，不仅仅是最近几个小时。而是经历了那个可怕的冬天。但现在他们已经到达了极限，每个人都有一个崩溃点。勒温豪普理事后说：“我恳求、威胁、咒骂并挥舞拳头，但一切都是
The Russian guns are firing faster and faster. They're ripping holes in the Swedish line, but the Swedes just keep coming. They're not firing, they're just advancing, you know, onwards and onwards. The Russian musketeers start firing, so there's a kind of hailstorm of musket balls, but still the Swedes keep coming. They don't fire a single shot. They want a kind of close action, very Nelson at Trafalgar actually.
徒劳的。就好像他们既没看到我也没听到我一样。”请记住，这些可是欧洲、乃至全世界纪律最严明的部队。而查理十二世和他的担架正用虚弱的声音呼喊着，不是吗？“瑞典人！瑞典人！”是的。他也无法重振他们了。不，他不能。
And they're closer and closer, just watching steadily. And then finally the Swedes are on them. And as always, when the Swedes attack, it is this kind of storm of muskets and bayonets and slashing swords. They are not the best soldiers in Europe for nothing. They smash into the Russian line. They are not the best soldiers in Europe for nothing. They smash into the Russian line, they start to push it back. On the right hand side, they are pushing the
事实上，这就像海浪拍打在他们头顶一样。你知道，绿制服的浪潮一波接一波地涌来。海啸。海啸，完全如此。短短半小时内，这支以如此勇气推进的瑞典步兵几乎被全歼，骑兵也在俄国炮火下遭到毁灭性打击。赖恩舍尔德被俘。查理差一点被俘。他的担架手被击毙。另一名军官——记住查理的脚伤得很重——另一名军官把他拖上一匹马。
green coats backwards. You know, for a moment it feels like the Swedes are going to do it. And actually amid all this, Peter is supposedly three times brought close to death. So once a Swedish musket ball knocks off his hat, another Swedish musket ball hits his saddle, and a third Swedish musket ball, I can sense what you're going to say about this Tom, is deflected by a cross around his neck that once belonged to the Emperor Constantine the Great. That definitely happened. Yeah, of course that happened. That's not a story from Russian propaganda at all. Of course, had Peter fallen, the result of this might have been very different.
但在混乱中，他脚上的绷带脱落了，伤口重新裂开，鲜血从他的脚上喷涌而出。他被扶上的这匹马随后被击倒，他们不得不把他拖下来扶上另一匹马，到处都是血。他们不知怎的带着他逃走了，并与同样成功逃脱的勒温豪普特会合，他们带着残存的军队向南疾驰。所以在短短几个小时内，瑞典人阵亡、受伤或被俘了 10,000 人。俄国人阵亡仅 1,500 人，受伤约 3,000 人。这对彼得的军队来说是一场压倒性的胜利。彼得将俘虏的瑞典军官带到他的帐篷里。
And the map of Europe might look different today, but he doesn't fall. God is with him, not with the Swedes. And what happens next is a very familiar story from other battles that we've done in this podcast. As the Swedes press forward, the gaps between their left and right become wider and wider. Peter throws in more reserves. The Swedes become engulfed and sort of encircled, especially on the right. Their momentum slows and as they slow and as the Russians kind of swarm around them, their morale begins to waver and then to break. And then the first Swedes begin to run and then it proves infectious.
欧洲的版图今天可能会有所不同，但他没有倒下。上帝与他同在，而不是与瑞典人同在。接下来的事情是我们在这个播客中做过的其他战役中非常熟悉的故事。随着瑞典人向前推进，他们左右两翼之间的间隙变得越来越宽。彼得投入了更多的预备队。瑞典人被吞没并被包围，尤其是在右翼。他们的势头放缓了，随着他们放缓以及俄国人蜂拥而至，他们的士气开始动摇然后崩溃。接着，第一批瑞典人开始逃跑，这种情绪随后具有了传染性。
It's like their momentum has carried them so far, but no further. Kind of like the adrenaline suddenly dropping. Exactly right. It's so much of, when you read accounts of battle, so much of it is about self belief and they've had their self belief has sustained them to an extraordinary level, not just in recent hours. But all through that terrible winter. But now they've reached, everybody has a breaking point. Lovv and Haupt said afterwards, I begged, threatened, cursed and hit out, but all was
就像他们的势头把他们带到了这么远，但再也走不动了。有点像肾上腺素突然消退。完全正确。当你阅读战斗记录时，很大程度上关乎自信，他们的自信支撑他们达到了非凡的水平，不仅是在最近几个小时里，而是在整个可怕的冬天。但现在他们已经到了极限，每个人都有一个崩溃点。洛文豪普特事后说，我恳求、威胁、诅咒并大打出手，但一切都
in vain. It was as if they neither saw nor heard me. And remember these are the most disciplined troops in Europe, if not the world. And Charles XII and his litter is kind of crying out in a feeble voice, isn't he? Swedes, Swedes! Yeah. And he can't rally them either. No, he can't.
是徒劳的。就好像他们既没看见我也没听到我。记住，这些是欧洲乃至世界上纪律最严明的军队。而查理十二世和他的担架正在用微弱的声音呼喊，不是吗？瑞典人！瑞典人！是的。他也无法重新集结他们。不，他不能。
And actually, it's like the waves breaking over the top of them. You know, this sort of wave upon wave of kind of green coats. A tsunami. A tsunami, exactly. And in just half an hour, this Swedish infantry that advanced with such courage has been almost completely destroyed and the cavalry has been decimated by Russian cannon fire. Reinskild was captured. Charles is almost captured. His stretcher bear is shot down. Another officer, remember Charles has got this terrible foot, another officer drags him onto a horse.
事实上，这就像海浪拍打在他们头顶上。你知道，这种一波又一波的绿色军服。海啸。海啸，完全正确。就在短短半小时内，这支以如此勇气前进的瑞典步兵几乎被彻底消灭，骑兵也被俄国人的炮火重创。雷恩斯基尔德被俘。查理差点被俘。他的担架手被击毙。另一名军官，记住查理的脚有严重的问题，另一名军官把他拉上一匹马。
But in the chaos, the bandages come off his foot, the wound reopens and blood starts pouring out of his foot. This first horse that he's put on is shot from under him, they have to drag him up and put him onto another horse, there's blood everywhere. Somehow they get away with him and they meet up with Lovrenhout who's also managed to get away and they gallop south with what is left of their army. So in just a few hours, the Swedes have lost 10,000 men killed, wounded or captured. The Russians have lost just 1,500 killed and they've had about 3,000 wounded. So a stunning victory for Peter's army. Peter has the captured Swedish officers brought to his tent.
但在混乱中，他脚上的绷带松开了，伤口重新裂开，鲜血开始从他的脚上涌出。他被扶上的第一匹马被当场击毙，他们不得不把他拉下来，弄到另一匹马上去，到处都是血。不知何故，他们带着他逃了出去，并与同样成功逃脱的洛文豪普特会合，他们带着残存的军队向南疾驰。因此，在短短几个小时内，瑞典人就损失了一万名阵亡、受伤或被俘的士兵。俄国人仅损失了1500人阵亡，约有3000人受伤。这对彼得的军队来说是一场压倒性的胜利。彼得让人把被俘的瑞典军官带到他的帐篷里。
And Field Marshal Reinskjöld is exhausted, kind of presumably covered in soot and blood and sweat and whatever, is brought into his tent. And Peter says, why did you invade such a vast country with so few men? You know, how could you dare to do that? How could you have the recklessness? And Reinskjöld says, my king ordered it. It was my duty to obey. And Peter loves this answer. He calls for wine and he says, atose, gentlemen, to my teachers in the art of war. And Rainscald says to him, well, who is that, your majesty? And Peter says, you, gentlemen. Very gallant, very impressive. And Rainscald says, then
雷恩舍尔元帅精疲力竭，身上大概沾满了烟尘、鲜血、汗水以及各种污渍，被带进了彼得的帐篷。彼得问他：“你为什么用这么少的人去侵略这样一个庞大的国家？你知道的，你怎么敢这么做？你怎么能这么鲁莽？”雷恩舍尔回答：“是我的国王下达的命令，服从命令是我的天职。”彼得非常喜欢这个回答。他命人拿来酒，说道：“诸位先生，我为我军事艺术上的老师们干杯。”雷恩舍尔对他说：“陛下，那谁是您的老师呢？”彼得说：“正是诸位先生。”非常潇洒，非常令人印象深刻。雷恩舍尔对他说，那么
well have the pupils returned thanks to their teachers. It's all very kind of, you know, well played, well played. Now meanwhile, what of Charles? Charles, that later that afternoon regroups with the Cossacks, I mean they really should have taken the Cossacks I think, the remains of the Swedish army and his baggage train. They all need to get away because obviously they're going to be destroyed. The only route, ironically, is even further south, even further away from Sweden. So they say, well, let's do it. They're riding through the afternoon and the evening. They're exhausted. They're obviously utterly crushed. They are frightened. I don't think Charles is frightened.
“学生们是否已经向老师们道谢了？”这一切都非常友好，你知道的，演得很精彩，演得很精彩。现在与此同时，查理怎么样了？那天下午晚些时候，查理与哥萨克人重新集结——我的意思是，他们真的应该带上哥萨克人，我是说瑞典军队的残部和他的辎重部队。他们都需要逃跑，因为显而易见，他们会被消灭。具有讽刺意味的是，唯一的路线是向更南方撤退，离瑞典越来越远。所以他们说，好吧，那就这么办吧。他们在下午和傍晚骑马前行。他们精疲力竭。他们显然已经彻底崩溃了。他们很害怕。我觉得查理并不害怕。
Probably not. No, everybody else is frightened. Well, it's ridiculously hot, so they're all dripping with sweat. I mean, God, they can't win. It's either they're freezing or they're just boiling. Charles is delirious. His wound is in a terrible state. He's slipping in and out of kind of sleep. He keeps saying, where's Reinskjöld? And everyone says he's been captured, Your Majesty. And he just doesn't seem to register that. After two days, they reach the River Dnieper and they don't have many boats. They don't have enough boats to get across and the Russians are chasing them. And basically, they're not going to get the whole, there's about 14,000 of them. They're not all going to get across. Who's going to go? And Charles says, well, obviously I won't go. I'll stay here. And
可能没有。不，其他人都在害怕。好吧，天气热得离谱，所以他们个个汗流浃背。我的天哪，他们根本无法取胜。要么冻得要命，要么热得像在蒸桑拿。查理神志不清。他的伤势非常糟糕。他一直在半梦半醒之间徘徊。他不停地问：“雷恩舍尔在哪儿？”每个人都回答：“陛下，他被俘了。”而他似乎根本无法理解这句话。两天后，他们到达了第聂伯河，但他们没有多少船。他们没有足够的船渡河，而且俄国人在追击他们。基本上，他们无法全部——大约有14,000人呢，他们不可能全部渡过河去。谁先走？查理说：“很显然，我不能走。我留在这里。”
his officers fall to their knees and beg him, you have to go. I'll stay here. And his officers fall to their knees and beg him, you have to go. You cannot be captured. If you are captured, Sweden is defeated now to the war. Our only chance is if you can get away and maybe you can raise support among the Tatars or the Ottomans. That's our only chance. And very reluctantly, Charles agrees and he is transported across the River Dnieper with the wounded and the Cossacks and what remains of his drabant elite bodyguard that we talked about last time. He gets across the river and they turn west across the grasslands heading towards the river Bug.
他的军官们双膝跪地，哀求他：“你必须走。我留在这里。”他的军官们双膝跪地，哀求他：“你必须走。你不能被俘。如果你被俘了，瑞典现在就输掉这场战争了。我们唯一的胜算就是你能逃出去，也许你能从鞑靼人或奥斯曼人那里争取到支持。那是我们唯一的胜算。”查理非常勉强地同意了，他同伤员、哥萨克人以及我们上次谈到的龙骑兵精锐卫队残部一起，被运送过了第聂伯河。他渡过河后，他们转向西方，穿过草原，朝布格河进发。
That's a great name for a river isn't it? It is the river Bug and that it's an important river because that is the frontier with the Balkans and the Ottoman Empire. He's entered the Ottoman Empire now. He's entering the Ottoman Empire and the men on the other side watched him go watch and watch until finally he disappears from sight. And what will become of him, we will find out some after the break. There are very few things that you can be certain of in life. But you can always be sure the sun will rise each morning.
这条河的名字真不错，对吧？这就是布格河，它是一条重要的河流，因为那是通往巴尔干半岛和奥斯曼帝国的边境。他现在已经进入奥斯曼帝国了。他正在进入奥斯曼帝国，河对岸的人们看着他离去，一直看着，直到他最终消失在视线之外。他将来会怎样，我们在中场休息后自有分晓。生活中能确定的事情寥寥无几。但你总能确信太阳每天早晨都会升起。
You can bet your bottom dollar that you'll always need air to breathe and water to drink. And of course, you can rest assured that with Public Mobile's 5G subscription phone plans, you'll pay the same thing every month. With all of the mysteries that life has to offer, a few certainties can really go a long way. Subscribe today for the peace of mind you've been searching for. Public Mobile. Different is calling. Your local Benjamin Moore retailer is more than a paint expert.
你可以笃定，你永远需要空气来呼吸，需要水来饮用。当然，你也可以放心，有了Public Mobile的5G订阅手机套餐，你每个月支付的费用都是一样的。面对生活带来的种种未知，少数的确定性往往能发挥巨大的作用。今天就订阅，寻找你一直在寻找的心安。Public Mobile。不同凡响，正在呼唤。你当地的本杰明·摩尔（Benjamin Moore）零售商不仅仅是一位油漆专家。
There's someone with paint in their soul. A sixth sense honed over decades. And if you have a question about paint, it's almost as if they can read your mind. I sense you need a two inch angle brush for the trim in your family room. Regal selected an eggshell finish and directions to the post office. Benjamin Moore paint is only sold at locally owned stores. Benjamin Moore, see the love. Did you know that our Sunday Times bestselling book, The Rest Is History Returns is now out
那是一个灵魂中流淌着油漆的人。这是一种经过几十年磨练的第六感。如果你对油漆有疑问，几乎就像他们能读懂你的心思一样。我感觉你需要一把两英寸的斜角刷来刷你家庭室的踢脚线。丽阁（Regal）系列精选了蛋壳光泽漆，以及去邮局的路线。本杰明·摩尔油漆只在本地拥有的商店出售。本杰明·摩尔，见证爱。你知道吗，我们《星期日泰晤士报》的畅销书《历史的残余归来》现在已经出了
in paperback. From finding out who British history's biggest lad was, to tracing the admittedly hazy ancient origins of Raiders of the Lost Ark, it's filled cover to cover with more curious historical moments than you can crack a lasso at, plus puzzles and a pub quiz. The Rest is History returns, available now in all good bookshops. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. Peter has triumphed at Potalva, one of history's most decisive battles. And Dominic, one of the measures of how decisive it is, is that Peter's conquests in the north and more specifically
平装本。从探究英国历史上最大胆的人是谁，到追溯《夺宝奇兵》中那些公认含糊不清的古代起源，书中从头到尾充满了比你用套索都套不完的猎奇历史瞬间，此外还有益智谜题和酒吧问答。《历史的残余归来》，现已在各大优质书店发售。你好，欢迎回到《历史的残余归来》。彼得在波尔塔瓦取得了胜利，这是历史上最具决定性的战役之一。多米尼克，衡量这场战役有多么决定性的一点是，彼得在北方以及更具体地说
on the Baltic are now secure. And that means that St. Petersburg is secure. And so he actually writes letters to his wife, doesn't he, and his family and his friends. And he says that his victory at Poltava is the final stone in the foundation of St. Petersburg. Yeah, that's absolutely right. But it's arguably much more than that. It's the final stone in the foundation of Russia as a great power. Well, let's just do a counterfactual because counterfactuals kind of serve to emphasize the consequences of what does actually happen. Let's suppose he had lost Poltava. How different would history have been?
在波罗的海的征服现在已经稳固了。这意味着圣彼得堡稳固了。所以他实际上给他妻子、家人和朋友写了信，不是吗？他说他在波尔塔瓦的胜利是圣彼得堡基石的最后一块石头。是的，完全正确。但可以说，这远不止于此。这是俄罗斯作为大国崛起的奠基石。好吧，我们来做一个反事实假设吧，因为反事实假设有助于强调实际发生的事件所带来的后果。假设他输掉了波尔塔瓦。历史会有多大不同？
I think it could have been very different. A lot of people listening to this might say, well, Russia was always fated to become a great power anyway. But remember in the 17th century, Russia had been a basket case for a long time. It could easily have been won again. So if Charles had won, there would have been nothing to stop him advancing on Moscow. Imagine if you take him to Pisa prisoner. He would have written into Moscow.
我认为这会大不相同。听到这里的许多人可能会说，反正俄罗斯注定要成为一个大国。但请记住，在17世纪，俄罗斯在很长一段时间里就是一个烂摊子。它完全可能再次被击败。所以如果查理赢了，就没有什么能阻止他向莫斯科推进了。想象一下，如果你把他当作囚犯带到彼得那里。他会骑马进入莫斯科。
He would possibly have installed a kind of Swedish client like he did with our friend Stanislaw Wleszczynski in Poland. He might have gone for Sophia, Pisa's sister. He might have brought Sophia back, exactly. Possibly after he had gone, there would have been a rising against Sophia or whoever it might be. There might have been civil war, it might have been Peter's camp against Sophia's, who knows. And there are all kinds of predators lurking on the borders, aren't there, who might have kind of gobbled up bits. The Cossacks might have declared independence. Right, the Ottomans, the Poles and so on and so forth. Certainly Russia would have lost
他可能会扶植一个类似瑞典傀儡的政权，就像他在波兰对我们的朋友斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基做的那样。他可能会选择索菲亚，彼得的姐姐。他可能会把索菲亚带回来，完全有这种可能。可能在他离开后，会爆发针对索菲亚或任何其他人的起义。可能会发生内战，可能是彼得的阵营对抗索菲亚的阵营，谁知道呢。边境上潜伏着各种各样的掠夺者，不是吗？他们可能会瓜分一些土地。哥萨克人可能会宣布独立。没错，奥斯曼人、波兰人等等。毫无疑问，俄罗斯会失去
the Baltic and probably would have lost Ukraine. And I suppose also it would have severely damaged Peter's policy of westernization. Yeah, that which would have been blamed, right? We lost our soul and we lost the war. Yeah. Absolutely. And I think what it would also have done is it would have left Sweden as the paramount power, probably in the Baltic. So Sweden would conceivably have kept Estonia, Latvia, the provinces of Livonia, as they were called, which, you know, when you get to the Napoleonic Wars and the Swedes are a much bigger player and the Russians aren't, you know, maybe things sort of changed in between those two points, but I think history would look very different.
波罗的海，而且很可能失去乌克兰。我想这也将严重损害彼得的西化政策。是的，这会被归咎于西化，对吧？我们失去了灵魂，我们输掉了战争。是的。绝对是的。我认为它还会产生这样一个影响，那就是让瑞典成为首屈一指的大国，很可能是在波罗的海地区。因此，可以想象，瑞典会保留爱沙尼亚、拉脱维亚、利沃尼亚省（当时就是这么叫的），你知道的，当你进入拿破仑战争时期，瑞典人是一个更大的玩家而俄罗斯人不是时，你知道的，也许在这两个时间点之间情况有所改变，但我认为历史看起来会大不相同。
Absolutely. And Peter knows that, I think, because that's why Poltava is so important to him. And he celebrated the anniversary of the battle every year for the rest of his life. And he lets everyone in Europe know, doesn't he? He sends kind of letters to everyone. And his swiftest courier, interestingly,? He sends kind of letters to everyone. And his swiftest courier, interestingly, goes to the Duke of Marlborough. So, you know, Charles XII's only rival for the title of best commander in Europe. Exactly. So Peter held a formal triumph at the end of the year in St Petersburg. And as always,
绝对是的。我想彼得也知道这一点，因为这就是为什么波尔塔瓦对如此重要的原因。他在余生的每一年都庆祝这场战役的周年纪念日。他让欧洲的所有人都知道了，不是吗？他给每个人都写了信。有趣的是，他最快的信使，把信送给了马尔伯勒公爵。所以，你知道的，查理十二世在欧洲最佳指挥官头衔上的唯一对手。没错。所以在年底，彼得在圣彼得堡举行了一场正式的凯旋式。和往常一样，
I mean, this is your point, Tom, about the Westernizing imperative. Uh, it's based on the Roman model. The troops marching beneath classical arches. Uh, they drag all the Swedish battle flags to the dirt. They make the Swedish officers march as in all such events with Peter. There's this weird element of play, acting and role play. He marches as an ordinary officer and it's his friend Fedor Ramadanovsky who presides over the triumph as the kind of mock czar. What happens to the Swedes, to the prisoners?
我的意思是，这就是你的观点，汤姆，关于西化势在必行的观点。呃，这是以罗马模式为基础的。部队在古典式拱门下行进。呃，他们把所有的瑞典战旗拖在泥土里。他们强迫瑞典军官行进，正如彼得参加的所有此类活动一样，其中有一种奇怪的假装和角色扮演成分。他作为一名普通军官行进，而主持这场凯旋式的是他的朋友费多尔·罗莫丹诺夫斯基，扮演类似沙皇的角色。瑞典人怎么样了，那些战俘怎么样了？
This is such an interesting side note actually. The generals were very courteously treated. So they were often exchanged for Russian prisoners or they were sent home as messengers with peace offers from Peter which of course the Swedes completely ignored as is their want. Some more junior officers actually chose to join the Russian army. This was not unusual. They were not expected to fight their own country but they would be sent to fight the Kazakhs or the Tatars or something. The rest of the junior officers were sent to Siberia and they
这其实是一个非常有趣的插曲。将军们受到了非常客气的对待。所以他们经常被用来交换俄国战俘，或者作为信使带着彼得的和平提议被送回国，当然瑞典人完全无视这些提议，就像他们一贯做的那样。一些较低级的军官实际上选择加入了俄国军队。这并不罕见。他们不需要去和自己的国家作战，但会被派去与哈萨克人或鞑靼人作战什么的。其余的低级军官被送往西伯利亚，他们
basically settled down and they became teachers, goldsmiths, tailors, you know, they brought trades with them, their previous trades. Well, they kind of merged into the vastness of the Russian population, did they? They did. But if you were a common soldier, it wasn't a great fate actually. A lot of them were sent to the mines in the Urals or they were sent to work in the dockyards of St Petersburg. A lot of them probably died eventually because those are grim fates. So when peace finally came in 1721, out of the 40,000 men who had marched into Ukraine with Charles XII, only about 5,000 ever went home. So that kind of tells its own story. Now you mentioned about Peter
基本上在那里定居下来，成了教师、金匠、裁缝，你知道的，他们把手艺带到了那里，他们以前的手艺。好吧，他们算是融入了庞大的俄罗斯人口中，是吗？是的。但如果你是一个普通士兵，那其实并不是什么好命运。他们中的许多人被送到乌拉尔山的矿山里，或者被派去在圣彼得堡的造船厂做工。他们中的许多人最终可能死去了，因为那是严酷的命运。所以当1721年和平终于到来时，在跟随查理十二世进入乌克兰的40,000名士兵中，只有大约5,000人回到了家乡。所以这本身就说明了一切。现在你提到了彼得
writing to everybody, he becomes now an extraordinary European celebrity. So the British who had previously thought, you know, Charles XII is the great man of the age now have to hastily recalibrate. The Duke of Marlborough actually wrote to his ally Lord Godolphin, he said, what a melancholy reflection it is that after constant success for 10 years, Charles XII should in two hours' mismanagement and ill-success ruin himself and his country. And all these people who've previously been Charles XII fans suddenly becoming Peter Stans. Peter Stans. So the most shameless example is the philosopher Leibniz, who had previously said he loved the Swedes so much that he wanted
写信给所有人，他现在成为了一个非凡的欧洲名人。所以此前认为“查理十二世是这个时代伟人”的英国人，现在不得不仓促重新进行评估。马尔伯勒公爵实际上写信给他的盟友戈多芬勋爵，他说：“在持续了十年的不断成功之后，查理十二世却在两个小时的管理不善和失利中毁掉了自己和国家，这是一个多么令人感伤的沉思啊。”所有这些以前是查理十二世粉丝的人，突然间变成了彼得的狂热粉丝。彼得的狂热粉丝。所以最无耻的例子就是哲学家莱布尼茨，他以前曾说过他非常喜欢瑞典人，以至于他想
to see their empire stretch all the way to Mongolia. And now Leibniz said, oh, Peter's victory was for the good of the human race. Here's a man whom God has destined for great work. And he wrote to Peter and said, would you like me to design the medal for you to celebrate your victory? Shameless. Yeah, it is shameless. It's very kind of tech billionaire after November 2024, isn't it? Invited to Peter's inauguration. Exactly.
看到他们的帝国一直延伸到蒙古。而现在莱布尼茨却说：“哦，彼得的胜利是为了全人类的福祉。这是一个上帝注定要成就伟大事业的人。”他写信给彼得说：“您想让我为您设计一枚纪念您胜利的奖章吗？”真无耻。是的，确实很无耻。这有点像2024年11月之后的科技亿万富翁，不是吗？被邀请参加彼得的就职典礼。没错。
Sit in the front row. And everybody now wants to ally with Russia. So the Danes re-enter the war, they invade southern Sweden. Augustus the Strong, a fox-tossing friend, he cancels his abdication as King of Poland, he invades Poland from Saxony and he reclaims his throne from the puppet Stanisław Fleszczyński, who now leaves this story sadly, so I won't get the chance to say his name. So he tosses foxes, but he is himself a jackal. He is a jackal. There's a very funny scene when Augustus and Peter meet for the first time after this in a place called Toruy, which we talked about in our episode about the wonders
坐在前排。现在所有人都想与俄罗斯结盟。于是丹麦重新加入战争，他们入侵了瑞典南部。强者奥古斯都，那个扔狐狸的朋友，取消了他作为波兰国王的退位，他从萨克森入侵波兰，并从傀儡斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基手中夺回了王位，后者现在悲哀地退出了这个故事，所以我以后没机会说他的名字了。所以他扔狐狸，但他自己却是一只豺狼。他是一只豺狼。有一个非常有趣的场景，奥古斯都和彼得在此之后在一个叫做托伦（Torun）的地方第一次见面，我们在关于波兰奇观的节目中谈到过这个地方，波兰以姜饼闻名。他们在托伦见面，彼得对奥古斯都说：“哦，你最近怎么样？很高兴再次见到你。顺便问一下，我送给你的那把礼仪之剑呢？”奥古斯都感到非常尴尬。他说：“哦，我很喜欢那把剑，但实际上我把它落在德累斯顿了。”彼得说：“太遗憾了。不过真走运，我又为你准备了一把。”他伸手去拿
of Poland, famous for its gingerbread. They meet in Torun and Peter said to Augustus, oh, how are you doing? You know, good to see you again. By the way, where's that ceremonial sword that I gave you? And Augustus is very embarrassed. He says, oh, I love that sword, but actually I've left it behind in Dresden. And Peter says, what a shame. But as luck would have it, I've got another one for you. And he reaches
这把剑，并把它交给了奥古斯都。这就是那把原版的剑，俄国人在波尔塔瓦查理十二世的行李中发现了它。所以大家面面相觑，满脸通红，满脸通红。从这个时候开始，以前与彼得平起平坐、甚至可能认为自己比彼得地位更高的奥古斯都，非常明显地成了一个俄罗斯的傀儡。事实上，从这个时候起，波兰在某些方面不过是俄罗斯的一个保护国。因此，原本预留给波兰的所有波罗的海征服成果，都被俄罗斯占有了。从长远来看，波兰当然最终会被瓜分。所以这是俄罗斯权力的阴影第一次蔓延到
for this sword and he hands it to Augustus. And it is the original sword, which the Russians had found in Charles XII's baggage in Poltover. So red faces all round, red faces all round. And from this point onwards, Augustus, who previously had been Peter's equal, perhaps had even seen himself as Peter's senior figure, is very obviously a Russian client. And actually Poland from this point onwards is little more in some ways than a Russian protectorate. So all the Baltic conquests, which had been earmarked for Poland, Russia takes them. And in the long run, of course, Poland will end up being partitioned. And so this is for the first time that the shadow of Russian power is spreading across
东欧。是的，完全正确。那么，查理怎么样了？因为我们离开时他正骑马进入奥斯曼帝国。他怎么了？好吧，一有消息传到君士坦丁堡，说查理十二世已经穿过了布格河并进入了巴尔干半岛。苏丹艾哈迈德三世，他是一个非常随和的人。他酷爱诗歌、绘画和花卉。他就像你那种冒着气泡的喷泉。是的。果汁冰糕。是的，属于果汁冰糕流派的奥斯曼苏丹。他说：“好吧，伊斯兰教告诉我们，
Eastern Europe. Yes, exactly. Now, what about Charles? See, because we left him riding into the Ottoman Empire. What's happened to him? Well, as soon as word reaches Constantinople, Charles XII has crossed the river Bug and is in the Balkans. The Sultan, Ahmed III, he's a very amiable person. He loves a bit of poetry and painting and flowers. He's your kind of bubbling fountain. Yeah. Sherbet. Yeah, Sherbet kind of school of Ottoman Sultan. And he says, well, Islam tells us
我们在欢迎难民时应该非常慷慨。”他说：“我们会安顿查理和他的手下，我们在德涅斯特河畔为他们建立一个难民营，就在摩尔多瓦那个名字很好听的本德（Bender）镇附近，在今天的摩尔多瓦。”所以查理，我的意思是，他的伤势正在慢慢好转。他非常沮丧。他没有同他一起来的伊万·马泽帕那么沮丧。马泽帕基本上是心碎而死的，我想，就是因为抑郁。所以查理在本德的营地里，每个人都认为，他会在那里待上
we should be very generous when we welcome refugees. And he says, we'll put Charles and his men up, we'll build a refugee camp for them on the River Dniester, which is near the splendidly named town of Benda in Moldova, in modern day Moldova. So Charles, I mean, his wound is slowly getting better. He's very downcast. He's not as downcast as Ivan Mazepa who's come with him. He dies effectively of a broken heart, I think, just depression. So Charles is in Bender in his camp and everybody thinks, well, he'll be there
几个星期，几个月，你知道的。我想问题是他怎么回去？是的。所以回家的明智路线实际上是走海路，因为彼得和奥古斯都在陆地上挡住了他的去路。法国的路易十四为他提供了一艘船。他可以向英国人或荷兰人求助。他们也可以商讨为他提供船只的事。但对于所有这些事情，代价就是瑞典
for, you know, weeks, a few months. I suppose the issue is how did he get back? Yeah. So the obvious way home really is by sea because Peter and Augustus block him on land. Louis XIV of France offers him a ship. He could turn to the English or the Dutch. They could also talk about offering him ships. But with all of these things, the price would be Sweden
必须加入正在激战中的西班牙王位继承战争的那特定一方。那场现在正在激战中的战争。而查理不想这么做，因为他已经在打大北方战争了。他不想打两场战争。事实上，查理心想，嗯，也许这并不是一件坏事。查理是如此疯狂地乐观。我很佩服查理这一点。这有点像弹性橡胶。我很佩服查理这一点，这种弹性橡胶般的性格，你知道的，他总是能东山再起。所以他说：“也许这一切都是最好的安排。你知道的，我可以和奥斯曼人谈谈，说服他们参战，事情就会顺利解决的。”所以他没有待几星期，也没有待几个月。他实际上
must join that particular side in the war of the Spanish succession, which is raging. Which is now raging. And Charles doesn't want to do that because he's already fighting the Great Northern War. He doesn't want to fight two wars. And actually Charles thinks to himself, well, maybe this isn't such a bad thing. Charles is so madly optimistic. I admire this about Charles. It's sort of India rubber. I admire this about Charles, this sort of India rubber, you know, he'll always bounce back. So he says, maybe this is all for the best. You know, I can talk to the Ottomans, persuade them to enter the war and it'll work out okay. So he doesn't stay for a few weeks and he doesn't stay for a few months. He actually
在本德待了三年，这简直太疯狂了。碰巧的是，奥斯曼帝国确实以与俄国开战而告终，因为彼得一直说：“你们能把瑞典人驱逐出去吗？我无法容忍你们境内靠近边境的一个营地里住着这样一个瑞典国王。”最终他在1710年下达了最后通牒，苏丹说：“好吧，不，我们不能容忍这个。”于是他对俄国宣战了。彼得制定了一个非常雄心勃勃的计划，要打进现在属于罗马尼亚一部分的地方，即作为奥斯曼附庸国的摩尔达维亚和瓦拉几亚公国。他说：“我要解放巴尔干半岛的东正教人民。”他在最狂野的梦想中还渴望重新夺回君士坦丁堡。
stays in Bender for three years, which is demented. Now as it happens, the Ottomans do actually end up at war with Russia because Peter keeps saying, will you please expel the Swedes? I can't tolerate the fact that you're having this kind of Swedish king living in a camp just inside your border. And eventually he sent an ultimatum in 1710 and the Sultan said, well, no, we're not having this. And he declared war on Russia. Peter drew up a very ambitious plan to march into what's now the part of Romania, the principalities of Moldavia and Wallachia, which are Ottoman vassals. And he said, I will liberate the Orthodox peoples of the Balkans. He also kind of aspired to retake Constantinople in his wildest dreams.
我想那从来都不是真的。不，但那是他形象的一部分，不是吗？所以这有点类似于子弹击中君士坦丁堡的十字架并弹开。在对奥斯曼战争出发前不是有一场阅兵吗？他的卫兵拿着红色的旗帜，上面有君士坦丁堡在异象中看到的十字架。上面写着“凭此标记你必征服”，这就是君士坦丁堡所看到的。所以他显然在利用这个想法做文章。我的意思是，这是第三罗马，让我们把第二罗马夺回来吧。我是君士坦丁堡的继承人。是的，他是。完全正确。我认为从长远来看，这具有极其重要的意义，因为这实际上是历史上俄罗斯第一次
I don't think that was ever. No, but it's part of his image, isn't it? So that it's rather similar to the bullet hitting the cross of Constantine and bouncing off. Wasn't that there was a parade before he leaves for the war against the Ottomans where his guards have red banners with the cross that Constantine saw in his vision. And it says by this sign you will conquer, which is what Constantine had seen. So he's obviously making play with this idea. I mean, this is the third Rome, let's get the second Rome back. I am the heir of Constantine. Yeah, he is. Dead right. And I think this is in the long run, enormously significant, because this is really the first time in history that the Russians
声称自己是所有东正教斯拉夫人、特别是巴尔干东正教斯拉夫人的捍卫者。因为实际上俄罗斯是唯一的独立东正教大国，不是吗？而且它现在是一个超级大国。所以很显然，对于东正教基督徒来说，这是一个相当重大的发展。是的，绝对是的。尽管进展得一点也不顺利，事实上对彼得来说简直是一场灾难，但我认为这会产生巨大的后果，因为如果你回想一下我们制作的关于通往第一次世界大战之路、第一次世界大战起源的系列节目，俄罗斯作为斯拉夫人保护者的这种想法，
claim themselves to be the champions of all Orthodox Slavs and particularly Balkan Orthodox Slavs. Because effectively Russia is the only independent Orthodox power, isn't it? And it's now a superpower. So obviously that for Orthodox Christians, this is quite a significant development. It is, absolutely it is. And although it doesn't go well at all, in fact it goes disastrously wrong for Peter, it will have I think huge consequences because if you think back to the series we did about the road to the First World War, the origins of the First World War, this idea of Russia as the protector of the
尽管他们相隔数百英里，而且是巴尔干半岛东正教基督徒的保护者。俄罗斯对君士坦丁堡有着这种若即若离的主张，这在1914年之前的酝酿中将具有极其重要的意义。不管怎样，当时的那次远征大错特错。彼得最终被这支庞大的奥斯曼军队包围了。幸运的是，大维齐尔名叫巴尔塔吉·梅赫迈特·帕夏，是一个相当年迈的人物，他其实并不太想要一场全面战争，他基本上放过了
Slavs, even though they're hundreds of miles away, and protector of Orthodox Christians in the Balkan Peninsula. And that Russia has this kind of tenuous claim to Constantinople, this would be enormously significant in the buildup to 1914. Anyway, the expedition at the time goes horribly wrong. Peter ends up being cornered by this massive Ottoman army. Fortunately, the Grand Vizier, who's called Baltaci Memet Pasha, is a kind of quite elderly figure and he doesn't really fancy an all-out war and he basically lets
彼得，只要求了极少量的让步。彼得不得不放弃亚速，那对他来说意义重大。所以那在克里米亚北部。是的，完全正确。他不得不放弃它，废除他的南方舰队，并放弃他在黑海的所有野心。但基本上也就是这些了。彼得对此感到相当宽慰。现在，当查理听到彼得被放走的消息时……他一定气疯了。嗯，他让自己蒙羞了。他骑马闯入大维齐尔的营地，穿着满是泥浆的靴子闯进了他的帐篷，土耳其人认为这是可怕的社交失礼。查理说：“你们在干什么？
Peter go with minimal concessions. Peter has to give up Azov, which had meant so much to him. So that's in the north of Crimea. Yes, exactly. He has to give that up and scrap his southern fleet and scrap all his ambitions in the Black Sea. But that's pretty much about it. And Peter's quite relieved about that. Now when Charles hears that Peter's been allowed to get away... He must be livid. Well he disgraced himself. He rode to the Grand Vizier's camp and he burst into his tent in muddy boots, which the Turks regarded as a dreadful social faux pas. And Charles said, what are you doing?
你知道的，放走彼得真是疯了。”土耳其人到这个时候——我的意思是，查理呆的时间比他们预期的要长得多，他们其实已经厌烦他了。所以他们只是无视他。我们稍后再回过头来讲查理和土耳其人之间日益扩大的裂痕。所以彼得不得不放弃黑海，并将自己投入到欧洲的战役中。现在疯狂的是，你以为瑞典人现在已经退出战争了。
You know, you're mad to let Peter go. The Turks by this point, I mean, Charles has been hanging around for a lot longer than they expected and they're actually sick of him. So they just ignore him. We'll come back to the growing rift between Charles and the Turks. So Peter has to give up on the Black Sea and he devotes himself to the campaign in Europe. Now the crazy thing is the Swedes you think, are now out of the war.
那就大错特错了。瑞典人失去了他们大部分的帝国，英格里亚、芬兰、里加、塔林、波罗的海。在1708至1709那个可怕的冬天之后，瑞典遭受了饥荒的蹂躏。接着又发生了瘟疫。在这场战争期间，瑞典令人难以置信地失去了大约三分之一的人口。其他所有人都群起攻之。这真的很像某种文明策略游戏，对玩家来说大错特错了，因为他们现在正面对着由俄罗斯、萨克森、波兰、丹麦、汉诺威和即将加入的普鲁士组成的联盟。而查理
You'd be quite wrong. The Swedes have lost most of their empire, Ingria, Finland, Riga, Tallinn, the Baltic. Sweden was ravaged by famine after that terrible winter of 1708-9. Then there was a plague. Sweden has lost unbelievably about a third of its population during this war. Everybody else has piled in against them. It really is like a kind of computer strategy game which has gone horribly wrong for the player because they are now facing a coalition of Russia, Saxony, Poland, Denmark, Hanover and Prussia are about to join in. And Charles
从本德的营地发回一条消息，他说：“完美，胜算对我们有利。我不会让出哪怕是一片碎纸片大小的瑞典土地。绝不。”事实上，瑞典人进行了非常顽强的抵抗。所以战争现在转移到了德国北部、不来梅和波美拉尼亚等地。彼得在那里对瑞典人展开了猛烈进攻，这对他是件好事，因为他喜欢去西方。他去了一个温泉疗养院。是的。
sends a message from his camp at Bender and he says, perfect, the odds are in our favor. I will not concede a single scrap of Swedish ground. No way. And actually the Swedes fight very doggedly. So the war now moves to kind of Northern Germany, Bremen and Pomerania and stuff. And Peter piles in against the Swedes there, which is great for him because he loves going to the West. He visits a spa. Yeah.
哦，他确实去了一个温泉疗养院。是的。所以我们还没去过德国的温泉疗养院，但彼得去了一个，因为他得了严重的绞痛。是的。所以他去了卡尔斯巴德的温泉疗养院，喝了那里的水，和那些留着胡子、身材魁梧的德国人混在一起。显然，根据一直陪同他的英国大使的说法，他一直在遭受
Oh, he does go to a spa. Yes. So we haven't had a German spa yet, but Peter goes to one because he's had a violent colic. Yeah. And so he goes to the spa in Carlsbad and he drinks the waters and he's hanging out with all those enormous Germans with mustaches and things. And apparently he had been suffering, according to the British ambassador who'd been accompanying him, a violent looseness.
严重的腹泻。哦，不。德国的温泉能治好这个吗？我想它会引起便秘吧，不是吗？对吧？那么多硫磺？我猜是的。我不知道。我从来没去过德国的温泉，但是……好吧，在最后一集中，我们会发现彼得和矿泉水之间发生了一些非常奇特的勾当。所以这很值得期待。我告诉你他在这次观光中还做了什么。你看到这个了吗？
Oh no. Would a German spa clear that? I think it would give you constipation, wouldn't it? Right. All that sulphur? I guess so. I don't know. I've never been to a German spa, but. Well, in the final episode, we'll find some very peculiar goings on with Peter and mineral water. So that's something to look forward to. I'll tell you what he also does in this sightseeing. Do you see this?
他去维滕贝格与马丁·路德进行心灵沟通。所以他去了路德的墓。你去了路德的墓吗？是的，我们去了。我们去了路德的墓。但与彼得大帝不同的是，我们没能进到路德的故居里面。对。因为当时正在关门装修。所以当彼得走进路德的故居时，馆长向他展示了墙上的一个墨水渍。馆长说：“这就是马丁·路德看到魔鬼并向他扔墨水瓶的地方。”而彼得的反应，他的行为很不合时宜。他表现得非常轻蔑。
He goes to Wittenberg to commune with Martin Luther. So he went to Luther's grave. Did you go to Luther's grave? Yes, we did. We went to Luther's grave. But unlike Peter the Great, we didn't manage to get into Luther's house. Right. Because it was shut for renovations. So when Peter goes to Luther's house, the curator showed him an ink spot on the wall. And the curator said, this is where Martin Luther saw the devil and he threw an ink pot at him. And Peter was, he did not behave appropriately. He behaved scornfully.
他说：“这么一个聪明的人，真的相信能看到魔鬼吗？”馆长说：“您想在墨水渍旁边签个名吗？你知道的，彼得大帝到此一游，非常令人印象深刻，就像访客留言簿一样。”而彼得在墨水渍旁边写道：“这个墨水渍还很新鲜，所以这个故事显然是假的。”这太不近人情了。我以为路德是在被关在城堡里时看到魔鬼的。在他的塔楼里。对，在一个塔楼里。
He said, did such a wise man really believe that the devil could be seen? And the curator said, would you like to sign the wall next to the ink spot? You know, Peter the Great was here, very impressive, like a visitor's book. And Peter wrote next to the ink spot, this ink spot spot is quite fresh so the story obviously is not true. That's very graceless. I thought Luther saw the devil when he was shut up in a castle. In his tower. Yeah in a tower.
所以这显然是一个……这完全是编造的。这只是一个旅游陷阱。好吧，彼得是对的。我的意思是，他持怀疑态度是对的，但我仍然认为作为客人这样做有点不够体贴。是的，但他的行为一贯都很不够体贴。想想约翰·伊夫林的园林吧。是的，还有对自己的亲生儿子，正如我们将在下一集里看到的那样。所以彼得去四处签名留念了。查理在摩尔多瓦。奥斯曼人对查理已经
So this is obviously a... It's just made up. It's just a tourist trap. Well Peter's right. I mean he's right to be sceptical but I still think it's a bit inconsiderative as host. Yeah but he's consistently behaved inconsiderately. Think about John Evelyn's garden. Yeah, and with his own son, as we will see in the next episode. So Peter's off signing ink spots. Charles is in Moldova. The Ottomans are absolutely
厌恶透顶了。他把这个临时的营地变成了一个永久性的瑞典基地。他建造了一个砖砌的大院。他有了一个办事处。他有了军官宿舍和马厩。土耳其人觉得：什么？这太荒谬了。这个疯狂的故事在1713年1月达到了高潮，当时苏丹和他的附庸克里米亚汗策划了一个阴谋，要将查理从他的营地绑架并弄出他们的国家。什么，直接把他塞进一艘船里？对，把他带到波兰。他们可以把他弄过波兰边境然后把他扔下。他们受够他了。瑞典人风闻了此事，开始准备进行围城战，而疯狂的是，
sick to death of Charles now. He's turned this temporary camp into a permanent Swedish base. He's built a brick compound. He's got a chancery. He's got officers quarters at stables. The Turks are like, what? This is bonkers. And this mad story reaches a climax in January 1713 when the Sultan and his vassal, the Khan of Crimea, cook up a scheme to kidnap Charles from his camp and get him out of their country. What, just bang him on a ship? Yep, take him to Poland. They can take him over the Polish border and just dump him. They're sick of him. The Swedes get wind of this and prepare for a siege and crazily
这最终变成了一场大战，有12,000名鞑靼人和奥斯曼近卫军进攻这个瑞典营地。有多少瑞典人？大约60人左右？对，我想大概只有几百人。查理在自己的房子里被逼入绝境，遭到土耳其炮火的轰击。土耳其人冲进来开始掠夺他所有的财产。查理向他们冲了过去。他现在的脚已经恢复了，这太棒了。他用剑把他们刺穿，或者类似这样的事情。
it ends up in a massive battle with 12,000 Tatars and Ottoman Janissaries attacking this Swedish camp. How many Swedes are there? About 60 or something? Yeah, there's like a few hundred I think. Charles is cornered in his own house under fire from Turkish artillery. The Turks burst in and start looting all his possessions. Charles charges at them. He's got his foot back now, which is great. He sort of runs them through with a sword or this kind of thing.
近卫军放火烧了他的房子。查理随后开始狂饮大量的白兰地，这是他碰过的第一口酒。是的，他平时不喝那种酒，对吧？不，我想他只是对战斗的想法感到太兴奋了。因为他喜欢战斗。高兴，我想是的。他很高兴。他带领手下突围冲出营地。
The Geniceres set his house on fire. Charles then starts necking loads of brandy, which is the first alcohol he's touched. Yeah, he doesn't normally do that, does he? No, he's just so excited at the thought of a battle, I think. Because he loves battles. Happy, I would think. He's happy. He leads his men in a breakout of the camp.
他们最终被土耳其人包围了，成千上万的土耳其人。罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K. Massie）关于彼得大帝的书中有对此非常精彩的描述。他说：“查理的鼻子、面颊、耳朵和手上都在流血。他的眉毛被烧焦了。他的脸和衣服被火药熏得漆黑，散发着烟味，他的外套被撕成了条状。但他依然带着那种惯常的冷静、几乎是带着好笑的漠不关心的神情。”好吧，他又高兴了，不是吗？他又回到了他熟悉的环境中。在这之后，苏丹感到非常尴尬，对查理说：“哦，我很抱歉事情失去了控制。我向你保证，这不会再发生了。”这里有一个关于此事的惊人之处。
They end up being surrounded by Turks, like thousands of Turks. There's a lovely description of this in Robert K. Mass's book on Peter the Great. He says, Charles was bleeding from nose, cheek, ear and hand. His eyebrows had been singed off. His face and clothes were black with gunpowder and reeking with smoke and his coat was torn into strips. But he had his usual air of calm, almost amused, unconcern. Well, he's happy again, isn't he? He's back in his element. And after all this, the Sultan is very embarrassed and says to Charles, well I'm so sorry things got out of hand. I promise you it won't happen again. And here's an amazing thing about this.
我非常喜欢这个细节。土耳其人把这一事件称为“卡拉巴卢克”（Kala Baluk）。它源于一个土耳其语词汇，意为人群。由于这起离奇的事件，“卡拉巴卢克”一词进入了瑞典语和芬兰语，直到今天，它在这些语言中仍然意味着混乱或骚乱。所以查理在土耳其又闲逛了18个月，最后苏丹终于与哈布斯堡皇帝达成了一项协议，允许他陆路穿过奥地利帝国和德国而不被拦截。查理是以悠闲的步伐前进吗？不，查理的表现完全在你的意料之中。所以他有一大群瑞典随从骑马同行。
I love this detail. This incident was called by the Turks, the Kala Baluk. It comes from a Turkish word meaning a crowd. And the term Kala Baluk passed into Swedish and Finnish, where to this day it means a ruckus or chaos because of this bizarre incident. So Charles hangs around Turkey for another 18 months and then finally the Sultan agrees a deal with the Habsburg Emperor that will allow him to travel overland through the Austrian Empire and through Germany without being intercepted. And does Charles go to leisurely pace? No, Charles behaves exactly as you'd expect. So he's got a big group of men of Swedes who are riding.
他坚持骑在他们前面，只带了一个人，而且他坚持纯粹为了好玩，进行乔装打扮，戴着黑色假发、假胡子，拿着一本假护照，化名皮特·弗里斯克（Peter Frisk）船长。这有点意思，不是吗？他在很多方面都是彼得的镜像，因为这正是彼得会做的事。你知道的，乔装打扮，四处旅行，采用较低的军衔。是的，这太荒谬了。而更荒谬的是，他没有去瑞典，而是
He insists on riding ahead of them with just one man and he insists just for the sort of the larks of going in disguise with a dark wig and a fake mustache and a fake passport in the name of Captain Peter Frisk. It's kind of interesting, isn't it, that he in so many ways is a mirror image of Peter because that's exactly what Peter would have done. You know, the disguise, the travels, the kind of adopting a junior rank. Yeah, it's bonkers. And what is even more bonkers is, so he doesn't go to Sweden, he
直奔施特拉尔松（Stralsund）这座城市，那是北部德国仍在被围困的瑞典据点之一。他在1714年11月深夜抵达，砰砰敲门，守卫打开门——天哪，是国王，我简直不敢相信。查理以每天超过100英里的速度骑马狂奔了1,296英里。非常令人印象深刻的是，他在这次旅程中甚至没有脱过一次衣服或靴子。大概到这个时候，他的脚不再化脓了吧。完全正确。所以他的袜子不会结满脓血了。
makes straight for this city called Stralsund, which is one of the remaining Swedish footholds in northern Germany under siege. He arrives late at night in November 1714 banging on the door the guard opens up oh my god it's the king I can't believe it. Charles has ridden for 1,296 miles at a pace of more than 100 miles a day. Very impressively he's not taking his clothes or his boots off once during this trip. Presumably by this point his foot is no longer superating. Exactly. So his sock wouldn't be caked with parson blood.
不，我想不会。没有碎骨头了。他们对他说：“哦，天哪，陛下，真难以置信你离开这么久后回来了。你想去斯德哥尔摩吗？”他说：“不，我是来参加围城战的，你们疯了吗？”所以这又是一次注定失败的事业，因为这座他在那儿待了11个月，几乎在城市陷落前数小时，他终于被说服离开。原因与他不想被俘虏是相同的。
No, I don't think so. Bits of splinter. And they say to him, oh my god, your majesty, unbelievable that you're back after so long. Would you like to go to Stockholm? He says, no, I've come here to take part in the siege, were you mad? So it's in yet another doomed cause because the city is clearly going to fall. He stays there for 11 months and literally sort of hours before it falls he is finally persuaded to leave. And for the same reason that he doesn't want to be taken captive.
他不想被俘虏，所以在1715年的平安夜，他15年来第一次踏上了瑞典的土地。他发现瑞典处于遭到绝对蹂躏的状态。俄国人一直在不断地袭扰它，它的农场全被毁了，剩下的人都躲在树林里以避免被征兵，他们失去了对芬兰的控制。实际上，我为了阅读这些资料掉进了一个巨大的兔子洞里。我最终阅读了关于18世纪初芬兰人口学的学术文章。芬兰历史上的这一时期被称为“大仇恨”（Great Wrath）。
It doesn't want to be taken captive and so on Christmas Eve 1715, he sets foot on Swedish soil for the first time in 15 years. And he finds Sweden in an absolutely ravaged condition. So the Russians have been raiding it incessantly, its farms have all been destroyed, what men are left are hiding in the woods to avoid being conscripted, they've lost control of Finland and actually I fell down a massive rabbit hole reading about this. I ended up What men are left hiding in the woods to avoid being conscripted. They've lost control of Finland. And actually, I fell down a massive rabbit hole reading about this. I ended up reading academic articles about the Finnish demography in the early 18th century. This is a period of Finnish history known as the Great Roth.
我的天，谁知道呢？好吧，瑞典人不仅失去了对芬兰的控制，也失去了对芬兰湾的控制，不是吗？因为他们有战列舰，但俄国人有桨帆船。所以有一场疯狂的《文明IV》式的战斗，令人惊奇的是，桨帆船获胜了。汉库海战（Battle of Hanku）。因此，结果就是瑞典人再也没有机会维持对芬兰的控制了。
I mean, who knew? Well, the Swedes have kind of lost control, not just of Finland, but also of the Gulf of Finland, haven't they? Because they have ships of the line, but the Russians have galleys. And so there's a kind of mad Civilization IV type battle where, amazingly, the galleys win. The Battle of Hanku. And so as a result of that, there's no opportunity for the Swedes to maintain their control of Finland.
事实上，芬兰不仅遭到饥荒和瘟疫的蹂躏，而且我认为公平地说，俄国人在芬兰的表现也非常糟糕。所以他们在公开场合鞭笞了数万人，有很多强奸，有很多谋杀。我认为相当令人反感的是，他们把芬兰人塞进烤炉里烤，我觉得这太糟糕了。这有点像童话故事。是的。他们把成千上万的妇女儿童奴役起来，卖给克里米亚人，把他们带到克里米亚。一些芬兰历史学家——这就是我掉进去的那个兔子洞——认为芬兰人口在这期间减少了一半。现在你会
And actually, Finland is ravaged by famine and by plague, but also the Russians, I think it's fair to say, behave very badly in Finland. So they flog thousands of people in public, there's a lot of rape, there's a lot of murder. They, I think, rather distastefully, they bake Finns in ovens, which I think is poor. It's kind of fairy tale. Yeah. They enslave tens of thousands of women and children, sell them to the Crimeans, take them down to the Crimea. And some Finnish historians, this is the rabbit hole down which I fell, think the Finnish population fell by half during this period. Now you would
以为面对返回瑞典后看到的这一切，查理可能会说：“也许现在是结束这场战争的时候了。”但没有，他说：“现在是时候了，你知道的，现在是时候结束这场战争了。”但没有，他说：“现在是时候了。你知道的，现在是时候投资了。股票只会上涨。”所以他找了一位新的首相，名叫冯·格尔茨男爵（Baron von Goertz）。我提到他只是因为我很高兴地看到他有一只假眼，这完全符合战争这个阶段一个首相的特征。他颁布了大规模的新税。
think confronted with this on his return to Sweden, Charles might say, maybe now is the time to end this war. But no, he says, now is the time, you know, now is the time to end this war. But no, he says, now is the time. You know, now is the time to invest. The stocks will only rise. So he gets a new chief minister called Baron von Goertz. I mention him only because I was pleased to see that he has an artificial eye, which is exactly as you would expect from a chief minister at this stage in the war. He says massive new taxes.
让我们回到老战略上来。我们要把敌人一个接一个地打倒。先是丹麦，然后搞定汉诺威，接着搞定普鲁士，然后为再次入侵俄罗斯做准备。太棒了。所以这是一种腓特烈大帝式的战略，因为腓特烈大帝——我猜他在下一代将成为伟大的军事统帅——他同样面临着自己希望的貌似破灭，却确实取得了胜利。所以也许查理十二世并不是完全疯了。我不知道。他的一些大臣问他：“陛下，您认为这需要多长时间？说真的？我们已经打了这么长时间了。”他说：“我想大概需要40年吧。”
Let's go back to the old strategy. We'll knock our enemies out one at a time. Denmark first, then we'll do a Hanover, then we'll do a Prussia, and then we'll build up to invading Russia again. Brilliant. So there's a kind of Frederick the Great approach, because Frederick the Great, who I guess in the next generation will be the great military commander. I mean, he similarly faces the seeming ruin of his hopes and does actually emerge triumphant. So maybe it's not completely mad of Charles XII. I don't know. Some of his ministers said to him, how long do you think this will take your majesty? I mean, really? We've been fighting for so long. And he said, I think maybe 40 years
让我们回到旧战略。我们将逐个击破我们的敌人。先是丹麦，然后是汉诺威，接着是普鲁士，然后我们再积蓄力量再次入侵俄罗斯。太棒了。所以这有点像腓特烈大帝的方法，因为腓特烈大帝，我猜在下一代中他将成为伟大的军事统帅。我的意思是，他同样面对着看似毁灭的希望，却确实取得了最终的胜利。所以也许查理十二世的做法并非完全疯狂。我不知道。他的一些大臣对他说，陛下，您认为这需要多长时间？我是说，真的吗？我们已经打了这么久了。他说，我想也许需要40年
should do it. I mean, you don't want to hear that. So he says, well, we'll start against the Danes and we'll start in Norway. So October 1718, he marches on Christiana, which is now Oslo. And in his way, there's a fortress called Frederiksten. And he, as always, very Nelsonian, he puts himself in the thick of the action, I think partly because he knows there is no other Swedish army. He has to inspire his men because it's this or nothing. So he's constantly putting himself in harm's way. And in the evening of the 30th of November, he's in the trenches outside Frederiksten and the Norwegians are firing kind of fire bombs from their cannons, which light up the sky and then their snipers, their sharpshooters can fire down at the Swedish sappers. About 9.30 that night, Charles climbs up the parapet of a trench and some of his aides say, oh be careful your
该这么做。我是说，你肯定不想听到这个。所以他说，好吧，我们从丹麦人打起，从挪威开始。因此在1718年10月，他向克里斯蒂安尼亚（也就是现在的奥斯陆）进军。在他的必经之路上，有一座名为腓特烈斯滕的要塞。像往常一样，他有着强烈的纳尔逊式风格，总是亲自冲锋陷阵，我想部分原因是他知道瑞典已经没有别的军队了。他必须鼓舞部下，因为这是背水一战，别无选择。所以他总是将自己置于险境。在11月30日的傍晚，他在腓特烈斯滕外的战壕里，挪威人正用大炮发射某种火弹，照亮了天空，随后他们的狙击手和神枪手便能向下射击瑞典的工兵。那天晚上大约九点半，查理爬上了战壕的胸墙，他的一些副官说，哦，陛下，小心点，
majesty, you know, watch it, come down. And he ignores them completely. And he's leaning on the top of the trench, he's kind of got his head on his hand looking out when they hear a sound, as one of them puts it, as if a stone had been thrown by great force into some mud. And Charles's hand falls away from his head and he's completely still, just looking out at this fortress. And then one of the officers says, Lord Jesus, the king has been shot. And he has. He's been hit by a Norwegian musket ball in the temple, which killed him instantly. And that was the end of him.
你知道的，注意安全，下来吧。而他完全不理会。他靠在战壕顶上，把头托在手上向外张望，这时他们听到一个声音，正如其中一人所形容的那样，就像一块石头被大力投进泥潭里一样。接着查理的手从头上垂了下来，他一动不动，只是望着那座要塞。然后其中一名军官说，主啊，国王中枪了。确实如此。他的太阳穴被一颗挪威火枪弹击中，当场毙命。他的一生就这样结束了。
So, I mean, he goes the way he would have wanted to go I guess. Exactly, just in an instant. That's it. The Swedes abandoned the campaign and they, for the first time in 18 years, Charles returned to Stockholm, albeit in an embalmed condition. And the news spreads across Europe. This extraordinary meteor of the age is dead. Peter was in St Petersburg when the message arrived and with a group of officers. And the story goes that he was visibly moved and tears sprang to his eyes and he said,
所以，我的意思是，他以自己期望的方式离去了，我想是的。没错，就在一瞬间。就这样。瑞典人放弃了这场战役，十八年来，查理第一次回到了斯德哥尔摩，尽管是以防腐处理后的遗体状态。消息传遍了欧洲。这位时代的非凡流星陨落了。消息到达时，彼得正和一群军官在圣彼得堡。传说他当时深受触动，热泪盈眶，并说道，
my dear Charles, how much I pity you. Does sound like Peter could have done it. Do you think it's a bit Julius Caesar and the head of Pompey? I mean, I guess it's the winners' prerogative, isn't it? The winner does take it all, including the right to do some performative weeping. Yeah, to performative weeping. And there was also a lot of performative mourning, so he ordered the Russian court into a week of mourning for his great rival. Even now, crazily, the war didn't end for another three years.
我亲爱的查理，我是多么同情你啊。听起来这确实像是彼得能做出来的事。你觉得这有点像尤利乌斯·恺撒和庞培首级的故事吗？我的意思是，我想这是胜利者的特权，对吧？赢家通吃，包括进行表演性哭泣的权利。是的，进行表演性哭泣。当时也有很多表演性的哀悼，他命令俄罗斯朝廷为他的伟大宿敌进行为期一周的哀悼。甚至到了现在，疯狂的是，这场战争又持续了三年才结束。
What? Yeah, the Swedes fought on for another three years and madly, madly, Britain joined the war on Sweden's side. George I piled in. Why? Because he was worried about the balance of power in the Baltic as a lecturer of Hanover. The Baltic mattered to him and he was worried that the Russians were too powerful. And here's the maddest thing. You know what actually ended the Great Northern War? It wasn't the death of Charles XII. It was the South Sea bubble. How so? It was the stock market crash in Britain that brought Sir Robert Walpole to power as the first Prime Minister. And Walpole, his whole policy was based on no foreign wars. Sort of peace and prosperity at home, a polite and commercial people. Let's make loads of money.
什么？对，瑞典人又坚持打了三年，而且疯狂的是，英国竟然加入战争站在了瑞典一边。乔治一世也插手了。为什么？因为作为汉诺威选帝侯，他担心波罗的海的权力平衡。波罗的海对他至关重要，他担心俄国人过于强大。而最疯狂的是什么？你知道究竟是什么结束了大北方战争吗？不是查理十二世的死，而是南海泡沫事件。怎么会这样？是英国的股市崩盘将罗伯特·沃波尔推上了首相宝座。而沃波尔的整个政策都建立在不打对外战争的基础之上。在国内追求和平与繁荣，成为一个文明且崇尚商业的民族。让我们大发横财吧。
He sold out a British ally who's been fighting against Russia. Well, that kind of is what I'm saying. To make Britain great again. Yeah, exactly. So he's basically says to the Swedes, look, I'm not going to fund this war. Like this is, you're clearly going to lose. It's mad. So the new Swedish king who was called Frederick decided he was settled.
他出卖了一个一直在与俄国作战的英国盟友。嗯，这差不多就是我要说的。为了让英国再次伟大。对，完全如此。所以他基本上对瑞典人说，听着，我不会资助这场战争。这，你们显然会输的。这太疯狂了。于是新的瑞典国王，名叫腓特烈，决定接受现实。
And in September 1721 at Nystad in Finland, his envoys signed a treaty that basically dismantled the Swedish Empire, gave it all away to Russia, pretty much in the Baltic. But Sweden itself retains its integrity, does it? Sweden itself maintained its integrity, exactly. But Karelia, Estonia, Latvia, Ingria, they all went to Russia and its footholds in Germany were all lost as well. So we'll end with Peter. The news of this treaty, I mean the Great Northern War which really did live up to its billing. I mean it's gone on for what, more than 20 years?
1721年9月，在芬兰的尼斯塔德，他的特使签署了一项条约，基本上瓦解了瑞典帝国，把几乎所有波罗的海的领土都割让给了俄国。但瑞典本土保留了其完整性，对吗？瑞典本土确实保持了它的完整性，没错。但卡累利阿、爱沙尼亚、拉脱维亚、英格里亚，全都归了俄国，它在德国的据点也全部丢失了。所以我们以彼得来结尾。这份条约的消息——我是说这场确实名副其实的大北方战争。我的意思是它持续了多少年，超过二十年吗？
Huge celebrations in St Petersburg, free wine and beer and fireworks and masks balls. And at the end of October, so a month later, Peter went to the Senate, which was a new institution he had set up in St Petersburg. And he said, I will cancel all unpaid taxes to celebrate the war. And the Senate and the Holy Synod said to him, wonderful, Your Majesty. And in return, we'd like to offer you a new title, Peter the Great, Father of the Fatherland and Emperor of all Russia. So in Latin, which would appeal to you, Tom, pater, patrii, imperator. So very Augustus.
圣彼得堡举行了盛大的庆祝活动，有免费的葡萄酒和啤酒、烟花以及化装舞会。10月底，也就是一个月后，彼得前往参议院，这是他在圣彼得堡建立的一个新机构。他说，为了庆祝战争结束，我将取消所有未缴纳的税款。参议院和至圣宗教会议对他说，太好了，陛下。作为回报，我们想为您献上一个新称号，彼得大帝，祖国之父兼全俄皇帝。所以用拉丁语来说，这会吸引你，汤姆，pater（父亲），patriae（祖国），imperator（统帅/皇帝）。非常具有奥古斯都的风格。
Augustus, exactly. Father of his country and emperor, not just Caesar, but Augustus. So he's not just Constantine, he's now Augustus. Exactly. And he agrees and there are huge shouts from the crowd, vivat, vivat, long live the emperor. And then Peter gave a speech, which again reminds us of this kind of Roman heritage. He said, by our deeds in war, we have emerged from darkness into the light of the world. And now those whom we did not know in the light respect us. I want our whole nation to recognize the direct hand of God in our favor during the last war and in the conclusion of this peace. It becomes us to thank God with all our might, but while hoping for peace, we must always remember the fate of the Greek
奥古斯都，没错。祖国的父亲和皇帝，不只是恺撒，而是奥古斯都。所以他不仅是君士坦丁，他现在是奥古斯都。没错。他欣然接受，人群中爆发出了巨大的欢呼声，万岁，万岁，皇帝万岁。随后彼得发表了一讲话，这再次让我们想起这种罗马传统。他说，通过我们在战争中的功绩，我们已经从黑暗走向了世界的光明。现在那些在光明中我们不了解的人也尊重了我们。我希望我们整个国家都能认识到在上一场战争中和本次和平缔结时上帝对我们的直接眷顾。我们理当全力感谢上帝，但在祈求和平的同时，我们必须永远铭记希腊
monarchy, meaning the Eastern Roman Empire, the Empire of Constantinople. And we must never grow weak in force of arms. And those are words that I suspect would resonate in the Kremlin today. And probably do resonate in the Kremlin today. But Dominic, that's not the end of the story, is it? Because obviously, if Peter is pledging Russia to eternal strength, he's not going to be around forever. And so he needs an heir who he can be confident will display the same strength, the same interest in forts and ships and military matters that Peter has always displayed. And whether his son, Alexeii is qualified to play that part. And if he's not, what Peter is going to do about it will be the themes of.
君主的命运，也就是东罗马帝国，君士坦丁堡帝国的命运。我们绝不能在武力上有所削弱。这些话我猜在今天的克里姆林宫也会引发共鸣。而且可能今天在克里姆林宫也确实引发了共鸣。但是多米尼克，这并不是故事的全部，对吧？因为很明显，如果彼得誓言让俄罗斯保持永恒的强大，他不可能永远活着。因此他需要一个继承人，他确信这个继承人能够展现出与彼得一直以来所展现出的同样的强大、对堡垒、船只和军事事务的同样兴趣。而他的儿子阿列克谢是否具备担当此任的资格。如果他不具备，彼得将对此采取什么行动，这将是
Our final episode in the series. So lots of stuff, father son relationships still to come. If you want to hear it immediately and you're not a member of the rest of the history club, you know what you've got to do. The rest is history.com.ly just sit it out wait episode six will be with you on Thursday thank you Dominic brilliant stuff and thank you everyone for listening bye bye bye bye Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence.
我们系列节目最后一集的议题。所以还有很多内容，父子关系的故事还在后头。如果你想立刻听到，又不是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你知道该怎么做。the rest is history.com。只需稍作等待，第六集将在周四与大家见面。谢谢你，多米尼克，精彩的内容，也谢谢大家的收听，再见，再见。嗨，大家好，你们还在。就在节目的最后，我对你们的执着深表钦佩。不过听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。
Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that there is of course any one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger network is. Goalhanger are
你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会不会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我的品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然有一个方法可以知道那会是什么样的体验。你可以打断广告的流程。你可以成为下一个汇丰尊贵理财（HSBC Premier）或在“历史其余部分”节目中广告过的许多其他了不起的公司之一。通过在“历史其余部分”以及高吊网（Goalhanger）网络的其他节目上投放广告，你可以将你的品牌展现在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是高吊网。高吊网是
the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个节目的幕后公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，高吊网非常希望能听到你的声音。你现在就可以访问 Goalhanger.com 登记你的兴趣，或者你公司的兴趣。那是 Goal，G-O-A-L，Hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R 点 com。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。